au confiné aux trois quarts depuis
aujourd'hui jusqu'au 6 avril écoles bars
et restaurants commerces non essentiels
doivent désormais garder portes closes
nous serons en direct de milan épicentre
de la pandémie en europe il ya tout
juste un an la série à présent avec un
triste anniversaire les 10 ans d'un
conflit meurtrier de pays est
aujourd'hui en ruine et sa moitié de la
population a fui les combats
elle les besoins humanitaires sont
énormes et la situation sécuritaire
reste très incertaine deux ans après la
chute de l'organisation état islamique
et terrorisent poursuivent leurs
opérations à la frontière irako syrienne
[Musique]
europe serait prête à produire spoutnik
vais le vaccin rue c'est en tout cas ce
qu'affirment les fonds souverains russes
un accord avait déjà été trouvé avec
l'italie il ya quelques jours pour la
production de 10 millions de doses du
sérum entre juillet 2021 et janvier 2022
des sociétés françaises allemandes ou
encore espagnols soirée elle aussi prête
à fabriquer ce vaccin ne reste plus que
la validation de l'agencé européenne du
médicament qui prend son temps et
précision de notre correspondant à
moscou antoine claireaux le scouting
venez pas encore homologué par l'agencé
européenne des médicaments mais cela
n'empêche pas la russie devrait en
coulisses pour trouver des laboratoires
susceptibles de produire le vaccin russe
et cela paraît être en bonne voie
d'après le patron du fonds russe
d'investissements directs responsable du
financement et de l'exportation du
spoutnik v
depuis le début de la lutte contre la
pandémie le fonds d'investissement russe
s'est prononcé en faveur d'une
coordination active avec tous les
partenaires y compris européens est
ouvert aux négociations le erdf a déjà
conclu des accords avec des entreprises
italiennes espagnoles françaises et
allemandes pour lancer la production de
spoutnik v actuellement des discussions
supplémentaires sont en cours pour
stimuler la production dans lieux
cela permettra de commencer à fournir du
spoutnik vais au marché unique européen
une fois l'approbation accordé par l'
agence européenne des médicaments
nous travaillons actuellement activement
avec le m&a dans le cadre de la
procédure de révision continue en outre
le rdf et ses partenaires sont prêts à
commencer à approvisionner les pays de
l'ue qui autorise indépendamment le
spoutnik vais le 9 mars un premier
accord avait été annoncé avec une
société italo-suisse pour une mise en
production du vaccin russes dans le nord
de l'italie
concernant la france le ministère de
l'industrie avait démenti tout accord
visant à faire produire le spoutnik vais
sur le territoire français mais entendre
kirill dimitrieff il semblerait que ce
soit en train de changer même s'il n'a
pour l'heure révélé aucun nom
d'entreprise et l'objectif pour la
russie et bien de vacciner un maximum de
monde et d'éviter toute politisation du
dossier de la vaccination
en effet notre tâche commune dans le
monde est de vacciner dans les meilleurs
délais la partie de l'humanité concernés
pour arrêter cette pandémie et le
président poutine s'est toujours opposé
à ce que ce sujet devienne un instrument
entre les mains d'hommes politiques
malhonnête et provocateur nous voyons
malheureusement que des tentatives de ce
genre ont lieu
nous avons entendu beaucoup de
déclarations notamment des pays
européens
les déclarations pas très fructueuse
mais tout cela n'arrête aucunement le
travail de bonne foi et méthodique des
scientifiques russes et des
représentants russes qui satisfont la
demande internationale croissante pour
ce vaccin sur le stream moscou estime en
effet que son vaccin fait toujours
l'objet d'attaqués de critiques
infondées
dernier exemple en date quand une
responsable de l'agencé européenne des
médicaments avait déclaré que se faire
inoculer spoutnik v revenait à jouer à
la roulette russe
un mauvais jeu de mots qui avait
fortement déplu du côté de moscou et
nous avons décidé de suspendre la
vaccination avec astrazeneca jusqu'à
l'avis de l'agencé européenne des
médicaments qui doit se prononcer demain
emmanuel macron contre aunis aujourd'hui
son premier ministre jean castex qui est
plénière encore à avoir confiance aux
accents suédo britannique
cette annonce intervient après la
décision de l'allemagne et d'autres pays
européens l'espagne
dernière en date ce soir de suspendre
l'utilisation de ce vaccin en cause
d'importants effets secondaires et la
mort de deux personnes vaccinées on
écoute emmanuel macron la décision qui a
été prise en conformité aussi avec notre
politique européenne
c'est de suspendre par précaution la
vaccination avec astrazeneca en espérant
la reprendre vite si la vie de l'om a le
permet et donc là aussi nous avons un
guide simple être éclairée par la
science et les autorités sanitaires
compétentes et le faire dans le cadre
d'une stratégie européenne
donc nous suspendons jusqu'à demain
après midi l oms tiendra une réunion ce
mardi autour de ce vaccin l'agencé
européenne du médicament elle se réunira
ce jeudi mais maintient que les
avantages d'astrazeneca l'emportent
toujours sur les risques l'espagne je
vous le disais vient elle aussi
d'annoncer la suspension alors quelles
sont les questions qui se posent les
détails en images
[Musique]
en
non
[Musique]
il
oh
[Musique]
mais
et côté mesures de restriction en france
contrairement au pas de calais et aux
alpes-maritimes l'île de france a pour
le moment échappé au confinement
l'épidémie de kobe 19 filles progresse
pourtant de manière importante
1152 patients en réanimation dans la
région à ce jour c'est plus qu'au pic de
la deuxième vague en novembre les appels
à seront peaufinées se multiplient cette
semaine s'annonce cruciale nicolas petit
en ile de france environ 110 personnes
sont admises chaque jour en réanimation
selon santé publique france le nombre de
patients lourdement atteints s'élève
désormais à 1150 2 contre 925 la semaine
dernière une dégradation de la situation
qui inquiète valérie pécresse
la présidente de la région à ce lundi
ouvert la porte
or confinement l'île de france est
clairement en sursis car le variant
angles est majoritaire n'est pas
seulement plus contagieux il est aussi
plus mortel et nos capacités de
réanimation sont saturés c'est au
gouvernement de décider mais aujourd'hui
on ne peut plus rien exclure et en
responsabilité si les mesures sont
justifiées
si elles sont proportionnées et
accompagner je ne m'y opposerais pas la
semaine dernière l'agencé régionale de
santé d'ile-de-france avait donné
l'ordre ferme aux hôpitaux et cliniques
de déprogrammer 40% de leurs activités
médicales et chirurgicales pour faire
face aux tensions hospitalières et des
transferts de patients vers des régions
moins touchées ont aussi commencé ce
week end
mais pour le président de la commission
médicale de l'assistance publique
hôpitaux de paris rémy salomon ce n'est
pas suffisant les transferts de malades
ne sont qu'une soupape de soulagement et
si la situation n'est pas encore hors de
contrôle
elle va l'être j'entends beaucoup dire
qu une semaine sans confinement est une
semaine gagner je n'ai pas la même
analyse pour moi c'est une semaine
perdue si jean castex n'a dimanche pas
exclu la piste dure confinement mais a
rappelé qu'il souhaitait pour le moment
l'éviter contenu les conséquences qu'il
pourrait avoir sur la population des
voix de la majorité commencent à se
délier à l'image d'aurore bergé la
députée lrm à ce lundi évoqué le risque
d'un confinement strict
je ne crois pas ce débat de savoir s'il
faut re confiné où une partie de la
semaine ou le week end s'il fort confiné
je crains que ce soit un confinement
strict auquel on doive se préparer avec
déjà 3 191 cas pour 100000 habitants
jeudi l ile-de-france frisé avec le
seuil des 400 cas fixé par jean castex
pour mettre en place des mesures
similaires à celles appliquées au pas de
calais dans les alpes maritimes alors
qu'un conseil de défense sanitaire est
prévue mercredi
emmanuel macron a déclaré ce lundi qu'il
y aurait sans doute de nouvelles
décisions dans les jours à venir
alors quelles sont les nouvelles
décisions susceptibles d'être prises par
emmanuel macron ces prochains jours
presque un an jour pour jour aura voix
après avoir déclaré la guerre aux virus
alors le président aurait-il dos à dos
face à la pandémie ou plutôt face à ces
variants place à notre décryptage avec
nos invités
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec un
attali r nous cherchons à l'iris co
directrice de l'observatoire de la santé
fait bien que de ville médecin
généraliste
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france on
vient de voir une situation très
inquiétante 1 nous sommes en tout cas en
ile-de-france pire qu'au pic en termes
de réanimation de novembre dernier dans
ce contexte en suspension du vexin
d'astra zeneca dans notre pays fait bien
que d'huile une très mauvaise nouvelle
pour vous si on base effectivement le
combat contre cette épidémie sur la
vaccination
je crois que c'est important en médecine
c'est la confiance et je crains que la
confiance soit un petit peu rompue
vis-à-vis de la vaccination elle peut
être aussi mes amis du monde de la santé
parce qu'on a pas mal d'avis
contradictoires
ce matin je recevais encore un mail de
la dgse m'incitant à commander des
vaccins astrazeneca la semaine dernière
on avait la possibilité de le faire
cuisse était plus possible donc il ya
vraiment une difficulté de bien
comprendre quelle est la ligne de
conduite dans la gestion de cette crise
et encore plus dans la vaccination
natalia nous aurons le voir on imagine
que c'est un petit peu
pardonnez moi cette excitation mais un
peu la mort dans la donc emmanuel macron
a dû se ranger au principe de précaution
puisque un par un les pays européens
décident de suspendre
ce vaccin astra zeneca il n'a pas le
choix aujourd'hui emmanuel macron il est
obligé de suspendre malgré ces chiffres
inquiétants
alors moi je suis pas médecin à
proprement parler donc je ne prononcerai
pas sur les chiffres inquiétants
franquin ça a été beaucoup commentée en
revanche je pense que dans la logique
qui a été une logique européenne
d'essayer d'avoir une stratégie commune
on le voit bien qu'ils aient eu du mal à
se mettre en place à peu près sur tous
les plans y compris sur cette décision
en terme de deux suspensions ou pas de
l'astral des cages et là j'ai un peu le
sentiment qu effectivement la france est
un petit peu la dernière à prendre cette
décision là donc je pense que oui on
voit beaucoup de décisions qui sont
prises un petit peu de ce type là en ce
moment c'est à dire un jour on peut
avancer dans une direction le lendemain
on change de pas et c'est vrai que je
pense qu'il faut renforcer un peu la
confiance et la lisibilité des
informations qui sont partagés on savait
que ça va être compliqué la confiance on
va regarder tous ces pays un qui suspend
d'astrazeneca re ils sont désormais 15
ce soir le danemark la norvège l'islande
pays bas à bulgarie irlande allemagne
france italie autriche estonie lituanie
lettonie luxembourg et donc dernier on
bat l'espagne fabien que deux villes
on le voit il ya des décisions qu'on
prend en france à l'intérieur de nos
frontières et les décisions qu'on doit
prendre sous la pression de
de l'europe c'est bien ça c'est ce qui
semble relever enfin en tout cas prendre
le dessus dans la gestion de cette
pandémie aujourd'hui en tout cas c'est
ce qu'elle dit c'est ce qu'elle dit
emmanuel macron puisqu'il a
effectivement citer aussi le cas de
l'allemagne qui suspendait le vaccin est
donc que la france suspende est aussi le
vaccin et qui ne se remet la décision de
löw et marque
je le redis je crois que ce qui est
important dans une politique de santé
publique et dans une politique sur une
pathologie comme celle ci il faut bien
sûr la vaccination
il faut bien définir des objectifs et
des parcs m l'objectif de la vaccination
est celle d'éradiquer la maladie de
réduire le nombre de cas de rituels au
nombre de cas graves et une coque vous
avez défini vos objectifs vous allez
définir le pourcentage de population
qu'il faut vacciner
et là on ne sait pas du tout quel est
l'objectif de 2 de la france dans cette
dans cette politique de vaccination et
c'est pour ça que ce flou le risque à
mon sens d'entamer vraiment de façon
importante la vaccination lui convient
mais aussi peut-être sur d'autres
vaccinations l'a vu avec le vaccin
contre le virus h1n1 ya quelques années
on a subi dès que les conséquences d'une
gestion de crise et là je suis crois
qu'il faut être extrêmement prudent
quelques kantienne nouvelles
thérapeutiques il faut quand même avoir
un petit peu de recul et peut-être qu'on
paye aussi cette précipitation vers la
vaccination à tout prix pour tout le
monde et je crains qu'il n'ait de
conséquences nathalie ernoult vous
parliez tout à l'heure de confiance à
cette décision de suspendre le vexin
intervient à peine 24 heures après
l'appel lors des manuels macro pardon de
jean castex avoir confiance dans le
vexin astrazeneca sa entame justement la
confiance encore plus des des sceptiques
au vaccin il était encore très nombreux
il ya à peine quelques semaines j'ai le
sentiment que c'est la lisibilité des
messages qui est vraiment jeu du côté du
gouvernement en tout cas français
comparativement à d'autres pays qui sont
qui ont des lignes de communication
beaucoup plus clair donc oui
effectivement ça peut ouvrir un espace
sur le doute je pense qu'il a quand même
beaucoup de scientifiques qui ont qui se
sont prononcés ce qui n'est pas mon cas
mais sûr sûr sûr ce vaccin en disant que
le nombre de cas étaient relativement
faibles comparativement au nombre de
personnes vaccinées
on a eu aussi en afrique une suspension
mais pour d'autres raisons parce que le
vaccin était moins efficace notamment
sur le variant sud africain donc moi ce
que je pense quand même c'est que on a
besoin d'avoir une lisibilité dans la
prise de parole et j'ai le sentiment un
petit peu comme on a souvent des prises
de paroles qui sont hâtives qui ne sont
pas toujours consolidé ni au sein du
gouvernement ni c'est à dire entre les
personnes du gouvernement et c'est ce
qui rend l'information difficile à
comprendre en fait un pur pour de les
citoyens que nous sommes et qui ne sont
pas forcément verser dans des
informations scientifiques ou dans la
littérature scientifique
toutes ces polémiques autour d'un héros
datar delestre avez vous aimé car on
parle que de lui aujourd'hui mais ce que
ça sympa clairement fait bien que de
ville vous vos patients ce qu'il ya des
gens qui finissent par se dire sur ce
mec ça on n'en veut plus mais je suis
assez étonné de voir que la en tout cas
du côté de mes patients il n'ya pas une
volonté extraordinaire de vouloir se
faire vacciner
mais c'est vrai que vis-à-vis de l'astra
dîner cas il y avait déjà un petit peu
de réticence
mais je ne suis pas sûr que ça pousse
les gens à se vacciner avec ce vaccin
qui le rappelle est disponible en ville
donc il va falloir trouver pour ceux qui
souhaitent se faire vacciner d'autres
moyens on sait que les centres de
vaccination
la logistique est un petit peu compliqué
donc là encore on est dans la dizaine
d'autres personnes dans la visibilité en
demande aux gens d'aller se faire
vacciner mais en fait c'est difficile
d'avoir des rendez vous les rendez vous
sont parfois du lait donc il ya un vrai
problème d'organisation vis-à-vis de
cette vaccination sur laquelle le mène
maintenant me reposer énormément sa
stratégie puisqu'il a encore dit
aujourd'hui on pourra ré ouvrir si un
certain nombre de gens sont vaccinés
donc il ya vraiment besoin d'avoir un
peu la visibilité était aussi une
visibilité mais efficace sortie crise
parce que je rappelle que les effets
négatifs de toutes ces mesures
commencent à peser lourdement
psychiquement socialement était aussi
médicalement sur la population donc
c'est important d'avoir une lisibilité
de sortie crise aussi dans cette
situation alors les pharmaciens
justement un cessez votre revanche le
maillage je fais un petit peu d'ironie
mais c'est la revanche peut être des
médecins généralistes qu'est ce que les
pharmaciens devait commencer à vacciner
aujourd'hui lundi 15 mars
ça va être un petit peu compliqué si
cette astra zeneca et suspendu natale
hier nous clairement le gouvernement
manque de chance sur cette séquence on
va parvenir
dans le passé de cette année il ya eu
évidemment les masses ensuite les tests
maintenant voilà une campagne de
vaccination qui est heurtée par des
vaccins qui sont suspendus par la
pénurie de vaccins le vexin français qui
n'est pas là décidément décidément comme
vous dites
pas de chance je pense que ça situe à
plusieurs niveaux je voulais juste
revenir peut-être sur la stratégie du
gouvernement français qui effectivement
est et de beaucoup de pays européens qui
étaient basées majoritairement sur le
vaccin d'astrazeneca et le fait de
suspendre en fait ce vaccin alors qu'il
était centrale dans les stratégies et
qui permettait compte tenu de ses
capacités de stockage dans des chaînes
de froid relativement facile à gérer et
habituel j'ai envie de dire permettez en
fait d'ouvrir le la capacité à vacciner
auprès de deux des médecins des
pharmaciens etc
là si on va au delà de 24 heures d'arrêt
ça va quand même beaucoup modifier la
stratégie de vaccination que ça veut
dire il faut se replier sur des vaccins
qui sont utilisés en chaîne de froid
extrême comme le fire biotech comme le
modern a hélas on retourne sur d'autres
logiques de stratégie de vaccination
avec beaucoup plus de difficultés à
élargir en fait la vaccination ce qui
risque d'avoir un impact sur eux
je pense sur le tout cas sur les
objectifs tels qu'ils étaient fixés donc
ça je pense que c'est en fait un premier
point est le deuxième je pense qu'il ya
emmanuel macron mais je crois que ce
qu'il faut il faut revenir aussi au
niveau européen pour repositionner je
pensais de discussions au niveau
européen ce qu'on a vu c'est la première
fois que l'europe a essayé de travailler
de concert pour négocier des vaccins ça
ne s'est jamais fait il n'y a pas de
politique il n'y en avait pas en tout
cas de politiques pharmaceutiques
européennes et encore moins sur les
achats donc ça c'est assez nouveau
je pense que on l'a dit et ça a été
beaucoup commentée il ya eu un certain
amateurisme un manque de transparence
dans la négociation y compris sur les
conditions négociées dans les contrats
qui d'ailleurs ne sont pas accessibles à
personne ni aux députés européens dans
leur intégralité
donc je pense qu'il ya plusieurs choses
qui sont cumulés ensuite il ya un n'a
aussi peut-être un petit fond votre
reportage avant par les politiques on a
un petit fond de tensions politiques
entre les britanniques et les européens
en particulier autour du vaccin
d'astrazeneca aider on va dire des
retards qui avait été annoncé il ya déjà
quelques temps
donc oui c'est vraiment c'est pas de
chance et ce qui va être intéressant
d'observer au delà de la france et la
capacité des européens à se ressouder
pour essayer de quelle que soit on va
dire le l'issue de deux des
recommandations de l'agencé européenne
du médicament de se ressouder pour avoir
une stratégie qui soit elle cohérente et
d'achat est aussi de mise en oeuvre de
mesures parce qu'on voit les mesures
sont elles mêmes très très hétéroclite
en fonction des pays chacun un petit peu
ça son regarde tout ça par son propre
prisme j'ai envie de dire fabien que de
vilains dernier mot sur les mesures de
restriction emmanuel macron qui sera
peut-être contraint de prendre des
décisions qui n'a pas forcément envie de
prendre l'aura compris cette semaine
notamment pour l'ile-de-france vous
pensez vous que c'est souhaitable de re
confiné l'île de france dans son
ensemble
c'est ce qui est fera que l'épidémie va
enfin marqué le pas en france
non j'ai toujours été défavorable aux au
confinement mesures de confinement qui
je rappelle n'ont pas montré
d'efficacité et au contraire ont des
effets négatifs assez important qui
risque d'être le long terme on voit
toujours autant de patients qui vont mal
on voit des patients qui consultent de
plus tardivement des pathologies qui
sont des gnostiques et plus tardivement
du fait de la limitation de ces de la
circulation de la population donc je
pense que les mesures de confinement de
soi locales nationales sont des mesures
qui ne sont pas utiles et je suis tout à
fait opposé à ce à ce type de mesures
ainsi ton plutôt les gens à venir
consulter moi je suis toujours surpris
de voir que des patiences autodiagnostic
mais ne viennent pas consultés je
rappelle qu'une consultation s'est pas
uniquement une prescription de
médicaments c'est aussi de l'information
c'est aussi la surveillance donc il
faudrait plutôt il en a encore dans la
nuit
militer des discours on n'entend jamais
mise de la santé ou le directeur général
de la santé inciter les gens à consulter
leur médecin
je rappelle que c'est essentiel de
d'avoir un avis médical
merci à tous les donateurs ir nouveau
fait bien que 2000 d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur arte france pour ce
décryptage est toujours en france alors
que les cinémas sont fermés depuis
plusieurs mois déjà de nombreuses
manifestations ont eu lieu ce week end
pour demander la réouverture des salles
dans le respect des règles sanitaires
idem pour les théâtres toujours occupée
par les intermittents du spectacle après
le théâtre national populaire de
villeurbanne c'est au tour de l'opéra de
lyon de se voir occuper afin de
contester la fermeture des lieux
culturels julien dureau revenir sur les
planches pour protester c'était
l'initiative d'une centaine d'étudiants
en majorité issus de l'école des arts ce
matin ces protestataires se sont réunis
afin d'occuper l'opéra de lyon dans
lequel seulement une cinquantaine
d'entre eux ont été autorisés à
s'installer un mouvement faisant suite à
l'occupation du théâtre de l'odéon
investi depuis le 4 mars dans le but de
rouvrir les lieux culturels
on vient avec les
des revendications qui sont communes à
toute la france qui ont démarré à
l'odéon tns et à la colline qui est
d'occuper les lieux de culture pour
revendiquer les droits de notamment
l'art en premier la réouverture des
lieux de culture mais aussi des droits
plus larges comme
commissaire péter la loi sur le chômage
chômage la prolongation de l'année
blanche et de manière plus générale à
l'armée sur la situation de tous les
précaires qui travaille dans le milieu
de la culture et dans d'autres milieux
outre les demandes de soutien au secteur
de la culture
ces manifestants demandent aussi une
aide plus générale
nombre d'entre eux sont venus afin
d'exprimer leur colère devant le peu
d'êtres du gouvernement face à la
précarité étudiante et l'enjeu que ça
représente pour nous là tout de suite
c'est évidemment tout ce qui est en lien
avec les intermittents parce que c'est
notre futur aussi mais c'est aussi la
précarité étudiante en général qui en ce
moment et on a quelques revendications
qui sont d'une urgence absolue sur les
deux points donc on ne se séparera pas
des deux poings et le fait d'avoir des
étudiants en art et des étudiants tout
court qui occupent un lieu culturel
ça nous permet d'amener ses
revendications la à la fois pour pallier
à la précarité de la jeunesse la
majorité écologiste de la mairie
lyonnaise vote aujourd'hui au conseil
municipal l'installation d'un rsa pour
les 18 24 ans une mesure qui doit entrer
en vigueur le 1er juin et qui concerne
environ 2000 personnes mais qui exclut
pour l'instant les étudiants reste avec
mon dans quelques instants nous
parlerons de l'italie au conflit mais
aux trois quarts depuis aujourd'hui et
jusqu'au 6 avril pour tenter d'endiguer
la troisième vague un peu plus d'un an
après le premier confinement et puis
direction la série avec les dix ans du
début du conflit le pays est aujourd'hui
en ruine et la moitié de la population a
fui des combats des combats
peut-être
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes le son et les dames on les
a déjà trop de dépenses trop d'état je
pense en tout cas qu'il ya trop de
bureaucratie c'est à dire un état
inefficace
tout ça a été financée essentiellement
par de la dette le problème est moins la
dette
en réalité moi je pense qu'on
remboursera la dette par la crise
donc il faut essayer de libérer
l'économie française et notamment le
travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique et est
accessible mais surtout elle n'est pas
productive les français n'en ont pas
pour leur argent
de ce point de vue à emmanuel macron n'a
rien changé par exemple par rapport à
son prédécesseur françois hollande
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un certain lien de confiance est rompu
entre l'eau politiques et les experts et
même les citoyens on est une société qui
est totalement percuté et on ne peut pas
considérer une démocratie vit
véritablement l'amplitude de ses
possibles et notre étude de ses valeurs
quand elle est à ce point confiné est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment on repart à
zéro par rapport à l'année dernière
la société ne survivra pas à une
succession de confinement une société
c'est pas de confinement
c'est la liberté c'est la créativité si
le sentiment d'exister d'appartenir
comment on va réorganiser le monde est
vrai que la pandémie c'est vivre
[Musique]
avec les accords d'abraham le président
américain reconnaît la souveraineté du
maroc sur le sahara occidental
la france comme l'europe a été absente
de l'ensemble de cette négociation qui
impactent directement deux pays dans
lesquels nous avons des liens
privilégiés depuis fort longtemps la
république algérienne et le royaume
humain des algériens évidemment
mécontents considère la décision
américaine comme une ingérence dans un
problème interne
le maroc a toujours été considérée comme
une menace politique économique et
militaire
face à cette situation conflictuelle
entre les deux pays la france aurait
ainsi l'occasion de participer à la
construction d'un maghreb pacifiées
[Musique]
20h30 soit les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez un an
après le début de la pandémie l'italie
imposant troisième confinement cela
concerne à la moitié du territoire
après un temps d'espoir le pays est
confronté à une troisième vague de kobe
19 plus de 150000 nouvelle contamination
ont été recensés en une semaine
et quand l'université bars ferment leurs
portes dans les grandes régions du nord
où les indicateurs sont au rouge
ailleurs les mesures de restriction sont
renforcés les explications de mathilde
romagnan et antoine auger rue inanimé
boutiques et restaurants fermés et un
sentiment de déjà vu en italie depuis
l'adoption par le gouvernement de
nouvelles mesures anti qu'ovide en
conseil des ministres vendredi dernier
les trois quarts de l'italie se
retrouvent ce lundi
confiné au moins jusqu'au 6 avril
prochain les écoles et commerces sont de
nouveau fermé après avoir rouvert depuis
début février un assouplissement décidé
trop tôt selon certains experts la
semaine dernière la situation s'est
soudainement aggravée avec une
augmentation de presque 15% des
contaminations
le week-end dernier l'italie avait
franchi un cap symbolique en devenant le
premier pays d'europe à déplorer plus de
cent mille décès liés aux qu'ovide 19
ces mesures sont nécessaires pour éviter
une aggravation de la situation et la
mise en place de mesures encore plus
strictes mais ces mesures-là
s'accompagne d'une action du
gouvernement pour aider les familles et
les entreprises
l'accélération de la campagne vaccinale
est la seule chose qui nous donne
l'espoir de sortir de cette pandémie
il y a quelques jours j'ai remercié les
italiens pour leur infinie patience
j'ai conscience que les mesures
d'aujourd'hui auront des conséquences
sur l'éducation des enfants sur
l'économie
mais aussi l'état psychologique de nous
tous si hier les italiens prenaient le
temps de profiter une dernière fois des
restaurants cafés ou d'une promenade le
retour à la vie confinée est un peu
brutal
je pense que c'est inutile de tout
fermer car ils ont déjà fait trois fois
et ça n'a rien changé
si lorsque nous allons rouvrir les gens
continuent à faire ce qu'ils veulent
les fermetures sont inutiles je suis
ouvert car je vend des cigarettes sinon
ça ne vaudrait pas la peine de rester
ouvert ça représente une perte d'argent
pour moi ici dans le centre il n'y a
personne
il ya quelques personnes qui se balade
pour prendre l'air et le soleil avec des
enfants pour nous les propriétaires de
restaurants il a rien à faire pas de
travail
les services de santé sont quant à eux
de nouveau sous tension
plus de 22 mille malades ducobu 19 sont
désormais hospitalisés et le nombre
d'admis en soins intensifs a grimpé de
25% en un mois dans le même temps la
vaccination avance trop lentement sur 60
millions d'italiens seuls 1,8 million
ont reçu les deux doses du vaccin
quant au ministre de la santé roberto
spezza
il n'envisage pas une amélioration avant
la seconde moitié du printemps et pour
en parler nous sommes en direct depuis
milan avec camilla genovese médecin
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir camilla genovese merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
quasiment un an jour pour jour après le
premier confinement l'italie se re
confine retour au point zéro
ça veut dire c'est ça un bon soir donc
ça oui c'est ça ça fait bien non lundi
c'était bien oui le neuf le 9 mars en
entrant confinement pour la première
fois en 2020 et là le 15 derniers à
nouveau en confinement du moins la
plupart des régions italiennes sont
confinés on nous appelle des zones
rouges dont les déplacements sont ne
sont pas possibles sauf dans en cas de
nécessité ou de travail les autres
régions sont des zones orange ces des
zones quand même qu'ils ont beaucoup de
restrictions
il n'y a qu'une seule région italie qui
est zones blanches c'est-à-dire où il
n'y a pas de restriction et c'est la
sardaigne la sardaigne et de pardon
pardon
une décision qui est qui est plutôt bien
accepté par la population est ce qu'on
imagine que le moral est pas vraiment au
beau fixe 1 1 an après de retourner
comme ça dans un confinement très strict
ça doit être très compliqué à vivre pour
les italiens c'est ça c'est ça c'est
surtout les jeunes et les parents qui se
retrouve à nouveau dans une situation
avec leurs enfants à la maison
les
on se retrouve la plupart des italiens
pensent que voilà un an est passé et on
est toujours la même situation beaucoup
se demandent qu'est ce qu'on a fait
cette année pour se retrouver à nouveau
en confinement mais c'est vrai que il le
faut il est nécessaire dans cette
situation de nour confiné afin de
limiter les comptages à quoi doit-on ces
mesures très strictes cet amant mesure
de précaution selon vous les chiffres on
ne le justifie vraiment alors c'est vrai
que il faut toujours essayer de prévenir
enfin ce qu'on dira italie c'est
prévenir c'est mieux de traiter donc
c'est vrai qu'avec une augmentation des
comptages qui maintenant est arrivé à
25000 countach par jour la pression sur
les réanimations et sur les services
hospitaliers augmente sur les urgences
on augmente aussi et en travaillant avec
des médecins généralistes
on voit aussi que les complets cas
augmente même les absences
asymptomatiques mais aussi les patients
qui doivent être gérés à la maison
augmente donc c'est quand même une
pression qui est de plus en plus forte
sur le système sanitaire
c'est la faute aux variants britannique
où la faute au relâchement des
restrictions selon vous un peu des deux
je crois que c'est un peu des deux c'est
vrai que ben il ya une augmentation des
cas qui sont dues aux variants on voit
ça en emilie romagne j'ai lu que
beaucoup de cas sont dus aux variants
c'est vrai que avec le beau temps qu'on
a en italie
beaucoup de monde se retrouve à
l'extérieur au 6 mai et
mais c'est vrai qu'il est nécessaire
voilà un certain moment il faut il faut
essayer de limiter comme on peut la
population générale doit essayer de
devenir en aide si aux soignants alors
des déboires aussi un pas que chez nous
en france des déboires sur le plan de la
vaccination puisque mauvaises nouvelles
en italie aussi astrazeneca était
suspendu c'est évidemment un coup de
frein dans la campagne de vaccination
c'est ça c'est sa belle c'est une
nouvelle d'aujourd'hui astrazeneca a été
suspendu par la fifa c'est l' agence
italienne du des médicaments
voilà en lombardie les vaccinations est
en train de ralentir un petit peu avec
ça on verra quels seront les effets sur
le long terme ou du moins dans les
prochaines semaines et dans le même
temps on apprend que ce conte nick v on
l'a appris il ya quelques jours allaient
être produits en italie c'est c'est un
espoir pour le pays
oui c'est quand même une opportunité est
aussi ça nous permet d'avoir plus de
vaccins qui sont très nécessaire en ce
moment parce que c'est vrai que on en a
mais pour commencer à vacciner le plus
de monde possible
vous savez être la couverture vaccinale
pour retourner à vivre normalement ne se
limite pas à vacciner une ou deux
millions de personnes donc le plus de
vaccins le mieux les médecins réagissent
comment l arrivée de ce vaccin russe est
ce que la confiance est là ben nous on a
confiance dans la science et on sait que
si les mains et life a donc notre agence
du médicament approuvé le vaccin
on fait confiance à ça et on sait que
c'est sûr pour nos patients et pour le
collège voilà merci camille genovese
médecins en italie merci d'avoir été
avec nous pour nous exposer la situation
sur place en catalogne une levée de
restrictions débute aujourd'hui face à
la tendance à la baisse du nombre de
quatre kobe 19 dans la région de
nouvelles mesures entrent en vigueur les
détails sur place avec notre
correspondante à barcelone les skis
singer la principale nouveauté concerne
la mobilité désormais les habitants
peuvent se déplacer librement en
catalogne
jusqu'à présent les catalans devaient
rester dans leur canton sauf pour
travailler ou autres motifs
exceptionnels
le confinement locale est donc levé mais
les déplacements sont autorisées
uniquement par bull sociale c'est-à-dire
par groupes de personnes vivant sous le
même toit
en cas de contrôle la police peut
demander des documents justificatifs et
puis du côté des commerces les magasins
non essentielles peuvent à nouveau
ouvrir leurs portes tous les jours avec
une jauge de 30%
il en est de même pour les centres
commerciaux et pour les boutiques de
plus de 800 mètres carrés
cependant pour la restauration aucun
changement
les bars et restaurants doivent fermer
leurs portes à 17h alors toutes ces
mesures entrent en vigueur pour une
durée de 15 jours minimum
mais la région se montre déjà optimiste
la catalogne a annoncé qu'elle pourrait
ouvrir à nouveau les établissements de
la restauration le soir et retarder le
couvre-feu qui actuellement en vigueur
de 22h à 6h aurait confiné depuis le 15
janvier dernier le portugal à présent
entrevoit le bout du tunnel est le
portugal qui commence dès ce lundi est
léger ces mesures après un confinement
total qui a commencé donc on le disait
le 15 janvier parmi ces mesures figurent
la réouverture des écoles maternelles et
primaires ainsi que les crèches après
presque deux mois de fermeture ces
neiges mans ouvrent le bal d'inde et
confine longue progressive du pays qui
compte avoir repris une vie quasi
normale à partir du 3 mai écouter cette
mère de famille
soulagé par la réouverture des écoles
c'est un jour de victoire les enfants en
avait assez d'être à la maison a fait
recours devant l'ordinateur ils
n'apprennent pas beaucoup il était aidé
par les parents et les profs mais ce ne
fut pas facile
retournez à l'école c'est important très
important mon fils est excité n'a
pratiquement pas dormi
il est resté longtemps à la maison
autant de temps à la maison pour eux ce
n'est pas facile rester à la maison sans
rien faire à part les cours sur
l'ordinateur
le portable et puis c'est tout il a pris
quelques kilos d'ailleurs maintenant il
va pouvoir les repères
ces images ont fait le tour du monde ce
sont celles de la ville d'homs dévastée
par le conflit syrien home ce qui fut le
théâtre d'un siège de trois ans qui a
pris fin en 2014 avec la reprise de
contrôle de la ville par l'armée arabe
syrienne
à l'occasion des dix ans du conflit
syrien emmanuel macron a de nouveau
plaidé pour une solution politique la
seule possible at il déclaré
de son côté londres a annoncé des
sanctions contre six alliés du président
al-assad dont le ministre syrien des
affaires étrangères
dix ans de conflit meurtrier donc en
celi et le pays est aujourd'hui en ruine
la moitié de sa population a fui les
combats
les besoins humanitaires sont énormes et
la situation sécuritaire est ce que très
incertaine
deux ans après la chute de
l'organisation état islamique les
terroristes poursuivent leurs opérations
à la frontière irako syrienne
jordi le mori début mars 2011 à deraa
une ville du sud de la syrie un groupe
de jeunes inscrits un tag au mur de leur
école ton tour est arrivé docteur une
allusion au président bachar al assad
ophtalmologue de formation les jeunes
sont arrêtés ce qui embrase une partie
du pays déjà secoué par le printemps
arabe
le 15 mars 2011 la mobilisation se
propage à l'armée les autorités
syriennes réprime les protestataires qui
peu à peu se radicalise et s'organisent
en mouvement armé le pays bascule alors
dans la guerre civile
les défections de soldats et d'officiers
des forces syriennes aboutiront le 26
juillet de la même année à la création
de l' armée syrienne libre les rebelles
ouvre plusieurs fronts et prennent alep
deuxième ville du pays à l'été 2012
le visage de la rébellion se transforme
avec l'apparition de nombreux groupes
jihadistes la guerre devient
confessionnelles opposant forces
loyalistes et intégristes violents
voulant instaurer la charia son
enlisement de plusieurs mois voit
l'émergence d'un nouveau belligérants
l'autoproclamé état islamique plus connu
sous le nom de dèche
il proclame en 2014 un califat sur des
terres conquises presque sans combattre
à cheval sur la syrie et l'irak
la tension internationale se tourne
alors vers la lutte contre cette
nouvelle menace
un nouveau front s'ouvre en 2015 qui
voit une coalition menée par les états
unis impliquant notamment la france les
jihadistes ont désormais pris entre deux
feux ils font face à la fois à cette
coalition et aux forces syriennes
ces dernières sont appuyés à partir de
septembre 2015 par l'aviation et la
marine russe est soutenu au sol par des
milices chi d'obédience iranienne le
gouvernement syrien récupère peu à peu
son territoire cette reconquête est
symbolisée par la reprise d'alep le 22
décembre 2016 tenu jusqu alors par
l'armée syrienne libre
moins d'un an plus tard le groupe etat
islamique père jaca au fil des défaites
les djihadistes syrie en déroute se
regroupent dans la région d'idlib dans
le nord ouest du pays une trêve avec
damas y est instaurée en mars 2019
mais depuis quelques mois une résurgence
du groupe etat islamique muer en
organisation clandestine mènent des
attaques meurtrières en syrie
face à cette situation les membres du
processus d'astana dont la russie l'iran
et la turquie reste vigilant la
situation dans le nord-est de la syrie a
également été discuté et nous avons
convenu que la réalisation de la
sécurité et de la stabilité à long terme
dans cette région n'est possible que sur
la base de la préservation de la
souveraineté et de l'intégrité
territoriale du pays
nous avons rejeté toutes les tentatives
visant à créer une nouvelle réalité sur
le terrain y compris les initiatives
illégales d'autonomie sous le prétexte
de lutte contre le terrorisme
dix ans après le début du conflit en
syrie le gouvernement de damas
contrôlent la majeure partie d'un pays
ravagé par la guerre mais dont la
reconstruction s'amorce au fur et à
mesure que les territoires y sont
pacifiées autre témoignage de cette
embellie cet été la population syrienne
sera appelée aux urnes pour
élection présidentielle au pouvoir
depuis 2000 le président bachar al assad
s'y présente à nouveau pour briller un
quatrième mandat à la tête d'une nation
dont la moitié de la population d'avant
guerre soit 22 millions d'habitants a
été poussé à l'exode
pour nombre d'entre eux le retour à la
normale du pays permet d'entretenir
l'espoir d'un retour prochain et avec
lui la fin d'une décennie de cauchemar
et pour en parler nous sommes avec un
randa kassis présidente de la plateforme
d'astana et coauteur de comprendre le
chaos syrien aux éditions l'artilleur
bonsoir avec les freaks merci d'être
avec nous on se rend compte que même si
l'état islamique a marqué le pas
évidemment a même été décimé la
situation reste extrêmement instable en
série oui tout à fait malheureusement la
situation et respect un stade c'est le
statu quo qui ont série il n'y a pas
même pas le début d'un processus
politique ce qui est malheureux l'onu
qui n'arrivent pas à aboutir à un début
de processus politique des acteurs aussi
qu'ils sont qui joue un rôle principal
en syrie je peux dire est
malheureusement c'est avec le govic
ovide 19
on est on est on est en mode on va dire
mode mode arrêt c'est à dire n'y a pas
de décision le dossier il est maintenant
entre les mains de me 2,2 ministère des
affaires étrangères russe a rien qui
bouge
il est certain que le président assad et
les îles et lila oui il est toujours
actuellement président de la syrie mais
il règne sur un pays en ruine une crise
économique qui frappe naciri la loi
césar qui va continuer il n'y aura pas
de retour toute façon le retour de la
syrie dans la ligue arabe
la crise va continuer et il y aura plus
de pauvreté tant qu'il n'y a pas un
début de processus politique
je suis pas en train de blâmer les
autres pays moi je crois qu'il ya une
erreur qui a été commise par tout le
monde par les pays
pliez a nui aux pays qui sont pas amis
où qu'ils ont plutôt qu'ils ont choisi
il avait une mauvaise décision
à l'époque quand ils ont pris la
coalition et le conseiller national
suivie par la coalition
suivi par le comité de négociation
syrien comme le seul interlocuteur
surtout dans un pays qui comme la syrie
qui a une diversité ethnique et
religieuse on peut pas avoir un seul un
terrain tel interlocuteur
alors oui en ce moment il faut rien
espérer à ça va être entre guillemets
quand on parle des élections c'est pas
des vraies élections
on sait très bien il va être il va
continuer à régner sur un pays en
faillite et et mais ce que j'attends
j'attends la femme de kobe pour
commencer une nouvelle initiative avec
notre série à alors justement emmanuel
macron lui a de nouveau plaidé pour une
solution politique c'est ce que vous
mais nous dira en substance la seule
possible selon le président français
c'est un bon diagnostic que pose
emmanuel macron enfin jusqu'ici la
france a quand même été impuissante sur
le terrain avec ses alliés oui
certainement toute façon l'europe est
impuissante façon de l'europe n'a pas
joué
ils n'ont pas une armée ils ont soutenu
à l'époque de président hollande ils ont
soutenu quelques brigades armées nous
certains malheureusement c'étaient des
islamistes ils ont ils ont détruit aussi
des armes à quelques brigade ou ce qu'on
appelait à l'époque l'armée l'armée
libre l' armée syrienne libre qui après
c'est tombé bien sûr ces armes ont les
autres on les a trouvés entre c'était
entre les mains des islamistes alors il
y avait il y avait de toute façon une
mauvaise décision
des erreurs qui ont été commises par
beaucoup de pays et pour cette raison je
crois que le président de macron a
hérité de 7
politique erronée et comme je les dis on
est toutes façons c'est la crise
aujourd'hui decaux vite
ce n'est pas la série n'est plus et
n'est pas une priorité pour beaucoup
beaucoup de pays
alors jean yves le drian lui a pointé la
responsabilité de la russie et de l'iran
soutient on le rappelle en du président
bachar el-assad dans ce conflit c'est
aussi la russie qui a eu devrait pour
chasser les islamistes
oui il est vrai aussi que la russie bien
sûr moi j'étais par l'intervention russe
en 2000 a enfin 2015 en séries c'est
pour chasser les islamistes si vous vous
rappelez il y avait quand même les
brigades qui ont pris le contrôle de
certains pays de certaines villes et
alzonne et régions et provinces en syrie
mais malheureusement c'est à dire après
je peux dire après le 2018 j'ai le
pressentiment malheureusement pour je le
dis je le considère et je considère
toujours la russie comme un pays ami
ils sont ils sont ils sont quand même il
n'y a pas un vrai décision c'est comme
si c'étaient ses pieds ou léthargie n'y
a pas une vraie stratégie par rapport à
la série qu'est ce qu'on va faire à part
parce que il y aura pas de
reconstruction série soyons réalistes
surtout avec à lui à césar il n'y aura
pas de reconstruction il n'y aura pas de
retour des réfugiés
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire après machine
en train de demander au régime
un régime qui est capable que pour moi
c'est un névrosé en fait même le
président syrien qui est déconnecté de
la réalité
je suis en train de demander ou de voir
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec certains
pays surtout avec la russie qui est
quand même qui a démontré une vraie
amitié et vraie volonté de trouver
solution mais depuis 2018 et n'y a rien
de tout en tout cas bachar al assad se
présente lui pour un quatrième mandat
est ce qu'il est toujours là
la situation non je crois pas je crois
que nous avons tous échoué opposition
opposant force de bien sûr opposition et
régime y compris bien sûr de charles
d'assad
il n'y a pas un vainqueur pour moi la
syrie c'est qui a perdu le peuple syrien
a perdu tout le monde a perdu parce que
régner sur sur sur un pays semi pays où
un pays en ruine c'est pas vraiment
c'est pas vraiment ce qu'on appelle la
présidence ou président est un pays
alors il faut faire je suis aussi
réaliste je cherche des moyens je
cherche aussi d'avoir des solutions
réalistes c'est à dire je crois toujours
un changement graduel
je crois aussi peut-être que lui il sera
réélu ça c'est sûr mais il ne peut pas
rester surtout la russie ne pourrait pas
tolérer situation en syrie pendant
beaucoup de temps et beaucoup d'années
est-ce que les sanctions restaurant
toute façon sur ce pays
tous ceux qui qui essaie d'aider le
régime ou d'investir en syrie seront
sous sanction il faut trouver une vraie
solution la vraie solution je crois que
peut-être ça pourrait à venir de la part
de ce régime c'est à dire les russes
peut-être je sais que c'est très
compliqué surtout avec la présence des
deux iront dans la région et ce retour
en syrie ce n'est pas si facile surtout
nous le savons très bien l'hostilité de
2,2 des rangs pour avoir un changement
même un changement graduel eux qui adore
toujours les élections organisées et de
savoir quel candidat doit être présenté
pour des élections
alors voilà tout est compliqué il est
certain mais peut-être ne pourrons
ensemble trouver un solution gratuit
elle peut être le régime pourrait aussi
ouvrir le pays
laisser les partis qui sont nés à
l'étranger les partis politiques de
d'avoir ou d'être en classe en syrie et
d'avoir des représentants pour en syrie
il faut
faut quand même animer la vie politique
en syrie commencé à animer une vie
politique en série on peut commencer par
aussi par des élections de parlement
après plus tard pour avoir des vrais
représentants de l'opposition et de
certains certains partis ils se trouvent
à l'étranger 2 d'avoir des représentants
qui peuvent être dans le parlement et
c'est à partir de là on peut nous
pourrons parler d'un changement ou d'un
changement graduel mais dans d un début
d'un processus
merci on va cassis d'avoir été avec nous
et toujours en syrie en dix ans de
couverture médiatique parcellaire et de
rhétorique anti gouvernementales un
regard occidental du conflit et les
rares compte rendu du côté damas sont
systématiquement qualifié de propagande
retour sur ce traitement médiatique du
conflit syrien avec thomas bonnet dans
un pays en proie à un tel conflit
obtenir des informations est toujours
compliqué un exercice qui peut s'avérer
particulièrement délicat tant les
billets sont nombreux ainsi le récit des
gouvernements occidentaux et souvent
repris tel quel dans les médias au
mépris parfois de la réalité puisant
leurs informations dans des sources
biaisé comme l'observatoire syrien des
droits de l'homme cités régulièrement
par des agences de presse comme la fp
pour donner des bilans chiffrés sur le
nombre de victimes dans le conflit par
exemple or cette source est plus que
contestable
l'osd achète en effet piloté par une
seule personne basée au royaume-uni et
s'appuyant sur un réseau de sources
locales
pour le moins partisane c'est déjà ce
qu'expose est la journaliste canadienne
eva bartlett en 2016 le sdf n'est pas
crédible
les militants sans nom ne sont pas
crédibles une fois ou deux peut-être
mais pas toujours
donc vos sources sur le terrain vous
n'en avez pas en ce qui concerne votre
agenda pas le vôtre mais celui de
certaines entreprises de médias c'est
l'agenda du changement
comment le new york times que je lisais
ce matin ou democracy now que je lisais
l'autre jour peuvent continuer à assurer
qu'il s'agit d'une guerre civile en
syrie comment peuvent-ils assuré jusqu'à
aujourd'hui que les manifestations
étaient non armés et non violente
jusqu'en 2012 ce n'est absolument pas
vrai dans le même registre il ya les
casques blancs présenté comme une
organisation humanitaire et donc comme
une source fiable par les médias
occidentaux
le groupe est en réalité bien plus
controversés ayant reçu des financements
américains les casques blancs sont
décriés pour leur lien direct ou
indirect avec des organisations
terroristes
en syrie un positionnement douteux qui
n'a pourtant jamais remis en question la
légitimité qui leur est accordée dans
les médias et qui pourtant s'explique
comment une organisation humanitaire
pourrait-elle opérés au sein de zones
parfois entièrement aux mains des
djihadistes s'en entretenir un minimum
de contact avec eux c'est pourtant
notamment en s'appuyant sur leurs
témoignages que les médias occidentaux
ont repris en boucle les allégations
d'atteintes chimiques et surtout les ont
attribué un peu à la hâte au
gouvernement syrien
malgré les démentis de témoins locaux de
journalistes sur place et les doutes
apparus dans les enquêtes de
l'organisation internationale pour
l'interdiction des armes chimiques
ces accusations ont conduit à des
frappes aériennes menées par les
etats-unis le royaume-uni et la france
les médias américains et occidentaux
devraient se rendre compte de leur
responsabilité dans cet incident il y a
quinze ans en 2003 au moment de la
deuxième guerre en irak
la maison blanche a eu recours à un tube
à essai et à son secrétaire d'état colin
powell
aujourd'hui washington utilise les
médias à la place d'un tube à essai à
défaut de pouvoir s'appuyer sur des
sources fiables la plupart des médias
ont donc décidé de coller à la ligne
occidentale
ainsi les islamistes sont présentés en
rebelles et leurs liens avec des groupes
djihadistes aux agissements insoutenable
n'apparaissent pas dans les dépêches
une omission qui s'inscrit étonnamment
dans le storytelling de washington
malgré ce parti pris des médias
occidentaux se mue en arbitre ainsi en
2018 le quotidien libération consacrait
un article au traitement de la guerre en
syrie par des médias tels que nous rt
france derrière les promesses de
révélations et les accusés
on d'intox se cachait en réalité une
enquête creuse et particulièrement
biaisé cerise sur le gâteau son auteur
s'avérait avoir des liens avec
l'opposition syrienne en remettant en
cause la version officielle avancée par
les alliés de l'otan notre média donc
été la cible d'attaqués disproportionnée
c'est oublier les précédents lors de la
guerre en yougoslavie ou en irak de
guerre ou les affirmations occidentales
se sont avérées erronées en syrie le
temps fera peut-être aussi son oeuvre
pour soulever les contre-vérités
disséminés pendant les dix années du
conflit
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur la crise sanitaire
avec sans doute de nouvelles décisions
dans les jours qui viennent prévient
emmanuel macron la france qui suspend
son tour le vaccin d'astrazeneca et puis
nous parlerons 2000 à cette jeune
adolescente iséroise type d' insulte
après des propos sur l'islam en janvier
2020 son compte twitter a été suspendu
durant 12 heures et ça a créé la
polémique
[Musique]
louis saillant est un ex commandos
marine il nous emmène dans les coulisses
de la guerre contre le djihadisme au
sahel l'ennemi la barre est parfaitement
légitime pour qu'on parle de jay liste
on parle de gens qui recrutent des
enfants
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême c'est vrai que c'est un terreau
qui peut favoriser l'extension du
terrorisme ne faut pas imaginer qu'il
suffit simplement d'avoir un pays pauvre
pour que l'islam c'est un mac sont
embrigadés ils ont été séduits ils ont
été manipulés et d'autres qui agissent
de manière parfaitement consciente et
lucide je respecterai toujours mon
l'adversaire même si je méprise
totalement son idéologie comme c'est le
cas pour sega liste
oui
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce lundi 15 mars 2021
sans doute de nouvelles décisions dans
les jours qui viennent déclaration tout
à l'heure des manuels macron alors que
la france suspend à son tour
l'utilisation du vaccin d'astrazeneca
après l'allemagne l'italie l'espagne ce
soir l'agencé européenne du médicament
tiendra une réunion demain quant au
vaccin russe poutine mais il sera
bientôt produit et distribué en france
plus tard at il cédé aux ennemis de la
démocratie comme l'affirment marine le
pen le réseau social a suspendu
momentanément hier le compte 2000 à
cette jeune adolescente iséroise cible
d' insulte après des propos sur l'islam
en janvier 2020 et jeune femme a répondu
à de nouvelles menaces à la suite d'un
poste une suspension même temporaire qui
a suscité nombre de réactions indignées
sur cette même plate forme
[Musique]
en allemagne le parti d'angela merkel
promet d'améliorer sa gestion les
pandémies une déclaration qui intervient
au lendemain d'un revers cinglant entre
deux scrutins régionaux un avertissement
sérieux pour les conservateurs à six
mois des élections législatives
fédérales qui doivent aboutir à
l'élection du nouveau chancelier
outre atlantique le gouvernement
gouverneur de l'état de new york dans la
tourmente accusé d'harcèlement sexuel
andrew pommeau pourrait être amené à
démissionner dans les jours qui viennent
sous la pression d'élus démocrates de
plus en plus nombreux
le président américain joe biden
lui voir ce que l'on telle enquête
apportera
nous avons décidé de suspendre la
vaccination avec astrazeneca jusqu'à
l'avis de l'agencé européenne des
médicaments qui doit se prononcer demain
emmanuel macron contredisons aujourd'hui
son premier ministre jean castex qui
appelait hier encore à avoir confiance
au vaccin suédo britannique
cette annonce intervient après la
décision de l'allemagne et d'autres pays
européens l'espagne
dernière en date ce soir de suspendre
l'utilisation de ce sérum en cause
d'importants effets secondaires et la
mort de deux personnes vaccinées on
écoute et men in black
la décision qui a été prise en
conformité aussi avec notre politique
européenne
c'est de suspendre par précaution la
vaccination avec astrazeneca en espérant
la reprendre vite si la vie de l'om a le
permet et donc là aussi nous avons un
guide simple être éclairée par la
science et les autorités sanitaires
compétentes et le faire dans le cadre
d'une stratégie européenne
donc nous suspendons jusqu'à demain
après midi
et c'est dans ce contexte tendu par la
crise sanitaire que jean castex a donc
réuni aujourd'hui par visioconférence
les organisations syndicales et
patronales pour un troisième sommet
social
le premier ministre y est accueilli à
distance les partenaires sociaux avec
les ministres de la santé
du lait du travail olivier verront
elisabeth bornes qui elle est positive
au kobe 19 l'objectif était de préparer
la sortie de crise à la suite de cette
réunion jean castex annoncé la
prolongation de la prime à l'embauché
les jeunes mais aussi le maintien de la
prime de 1000 euros défiscalisé à tous
les salariés écouter
au terme des échanges avec les
partenaires sociaux le gouvernement a
décidé d'autoriser à nouveau comme ces
deux dernières années le versement en
2021 d'une prime de 1000 euros
défiscalisées et exonérées de
cotisations sociales
cette prime sera ouverte à tous dès sa
ligne il sera par ailleurs possible
dan augmenter le montant jusqu'à 2000
euros pour les entreprises et les
branches professionnelles soit qu'ils
auront conclu un accord d'intéressement
d'ici la fin de l'année soit qu'ils
auront ouvert une négociation sur la
valorisation des métiers concernés
je souhaite évidemment qu'un maximum de
branches s'engagent dans cette démarche
notamment celles qui ne se sont pas
emparés de ce sujet l'année dernière
concernant la prime à l'embauché des
jeunes
j'ai décidé de la prolonger jusqu'au 31
mai et de la recentrer à partir du mois
d'avril sur les salaires inférieurs à
1,6 smic dans une logique de sortie
progressive des aides et pour en parler
nous sommes avec françois o merrill
président de la cfe cgc
bonsoir françois méline merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france avant
d'entrer dans le détail 1 globalement
est ce que ces annonces de jean castex
sont à la hauteur de vos attentes
c'est très difficile de qualifier
d'abord nos attentes
et puis là la qualité des annonces moi
ce que je voudrais dire sur le court
extrait que vous avez donnée de la
conférence de presse du premier ministre
c'est qu'une prime évidemment c'est
toujours une bonne chose c'est toujours
bon à prendre mais s'agissant des
métiers les moins bien valorisés en tout
cas c'est notre analyse à nous les
syndicats évidemment ça ne règle rien ça
ne règle rien parce que la question qui
est posée pour ces emplois là qu'on
appelle les emplois de la deuxième ligne
bien c'est la valorisation salariale
bien entendu ce sont souvent des emplois
très précaire mais aux conditions de
travail de vie très très difficile et
c'est bien de cela qu'il s'agit il faut
que dans des branches qui les
représentent bien aujourd'hui on se
saisisse du dossier qu'on regarde
comment faire évoluer ses rémunérations
qui sont trop faibles et comment rendre
attractif ces emplois mais qui ne trouve
pas preneur aujourd'hui et c'est bien
normal parce que quand un emploi n'est
pas preneur c'est que l'emploi n'est pas
suffisamment valorisé la priorité aux
jeunes
c'est une bonne chose pour vous les
annonces étaient tout de même pas
suffisant vous venez de le dire mais
tout de même les bienvenus justement en
faveur de cette jeunesse qui souffre
plus que jamais oui tout ce qui est tout
ce qui est proposé et qui répond à dans
la crise aux préoccupations
particulières que vivent les plus jeunes
d'entre nous de toute façon est une
bonne chose
alors nous la cfe cgc on a quand même
j'allais dire des préventions par
rapport à la prime à l'embauché qu'on
croit être assez mal employé c'est à
dire qu'en fait elle sollicite beaucoup
trop les effets d'aubaine
nous on le dit depuis le début ce sont
des dispositifs très coûteux et qui sont
financés sur l'argent public et qui en
fait sont assez peu efficace parce que
quand une entreprise n'embauchent que si
elle a besoin et c'est pas une prime qui
fait faire une embauche d'autant que en
plus pour nous c'est un peu un abus la
prime peut être versés pour des
embauches qui ne sont pas en cdi mais
qui sont en cdd une certaine longueur
donc on a des réserves sur le dispositif
par ailleurs on soutient le dispositif
qui consiste à aider par une prime
lambeaux juin alternant parce que c'est
vrai le dispositif d'apprentissage est
un dispositif on le sait très qualitatif
et qui permet de s'insérer beaucoup
mieux dans l'emploi on a des données
objectives des statistiques qui ne le
prouve ce qu'on souhaite quand même
c'est qu'on regarde dans les mois qui
viennent en vérité l'année prochaine si
ça n'a pas eu un effet de déflation sur
la capacité de cette formation
d'excellence donc la formation par
alternance et quel que soit le niveau 6
a pas eu un effet un peu contre
productif sur l'insertion dans l'emploi
aujourd'hui on peut pas préjuger moi je
pense qu'il faut se satisfaire du fait
que nous avons tenues en 2020 des
niveaux d'entrée en apprentissage très
élevé au delà même des objectifs il faut
probablement le reproduire en 2021
mais il faut être attentif à l'impact
sur le marché de l'emploi justement
l'impact sur le marché de l'emploi il
est évidemment spa vous que je vais la
prendre très particulier en ce moment
est ce qu'on peut vraiment sûr
tabler sur des réformes structurelles
dans le fond aujourd'hui et vous le
disiez les aides sont satisfaisantes
mais pas qu'eux mais à ton choix
aujourd'hui de délivrer des tout
simplement d aide et de ne pas faire de
réformes trop profondes si j'ose dire
écoutez c'est effectivement la question
clé moi je vous suis là dessus moi je
vais vous redire ce que j'ai dit au
premier ministre et au gouvernement
le choix qui a été fait en france de
soutenir l'activité à travers le chômage
partiel est un choix important courageux
il fallait le faire il faut se rappeler
que on la donnait un chiffre pour 2020
un coup de total du chômage partiel de
l'ordre de 27 millions d'euros m 7
milliards d'euros
donc c'est extrêmement important il faut
rappeler que sur ces 27 milliards can à
un tiers qui sont financés par l'unedic
c'est à dire par les cotisations sur les
salaires donc par l'ensemble de la
collectivité des salariés et pour deux
tiers par l'impôt donc c'est quelque
chose qu'il fallait faire nous nous
soutenons ce dispositif en même temps
que nous soutenons ce qu'on appelle la
pld c'est à dire le moyen pour les
entreprises de négocier des accords qui
vont mettre en place le chômage partiel
et la formation qui va avec tout ça il
me semble ça nous semble être une bonne
politique qui normalement nous met dans
une meilleure situation au moment du
redémarrage de l'économie bien sûr on
souhaite tous que les conditions
actuelles est bien ne seront que de
courte durée désormais qu'on pourra
redémarrer l'économie j'entends par là
tous les établissements toutes les
entreprises qui sont fermées par décret
et bien sûr le commerce la restauration
la culture les salles de sport etc
donc c'est bien de ça qu'il s'agit et il
est très clair que ces dispositifs là
sont des dispositifs utiles et qu'il
fallait faire il fallait une certaine
façon un peu de courage politique pour
le faire par contre je termine là dessus
il ya un sujet puisqu'on parle beaucoup
de la sortie crise qui pour nous est
absolument centrale et dont on ne peut
pas faire l'économie dans l'examen c'est
celui du partage de la valeur
c'est celui de la gouvernance des
entreprises et à ce titre s'il faut me
donner les 30 secondes
je pense qu'aujourd'hui 15 mars 2021 est
une date à retenir puisque je les ai dit
au ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
libé côté je veux partager votre peine
parce que ce sur quoi ce que vous aviez
fait comme un symbole de loi pacte c'est
à dire l'entreprise a mission a été
sacrément battu en brèche aujourd'hui un
puisque le pdg de danone qui avait
transformé son entreprise en entreprise
habilitée à mission est bien vient
d'être limogé
il n'ya pas d'autre mot par ses
actionnaires parce qu'il considère que
l'entreprise génère pas suffisamment de
profits pour ses actionnaires
donc ce problème là il est central il
est posé devant nous et tant qu'on
n'aura pas regarder cette question là on
aura énormément de mal à avancer dans la
réforme de la société de l'économie de
ce qui est pour nous absolument central
c'est-à-dire la question d'élaboration
de la valeur et de son partage françois
om-lille plus globalement presque un an
jour pour jour après le premier
confinement on voit malheureusement est
la lumière des chiffres qu'on n'est pas
sorti de l'auberge pour plagier le
premier ministre quelle suite pour le
quoi qu'il en coûte à la fin il faudra
bien payer et rembourser
oui bien sûr vous savez aujourd'hui ceux
qui ont payé beaucoup c'est les français
en fait un c'est les français qui ont
payé ce sont les jeunes qui payent
beaucoup
il faudra s'en souvenir nous avons tous
une dette vis à vis des jeunes les
jeunes de 20 ans qui passe le meilleur
de leur vie pour certains enfermés dans
leur chambre qui ne peuvent pas aller en
cours
les jeunes de 20 ans et un peu plus un
peu moins qu'ils ne trouvent pas du
travail comme normalement il devrait en
trouver
nous avons une dette vis-à-vis d'eux ils
ce sont les français qui ont financé le
chômage partiel c'est l'impôt se sont
pas beaucoup les bénéfices des
entreprises il me semble on vient nous
rappeler effectivement que l'année 2020
est une année dans lequel les marges les
entreprises ont été très très faible
certes
effectivement j'ai pas beaucoup entendu
que les actionnaires qui soi-disant
prennent tant de risques
raison pour laquelle il faudrait temps
les rémunérer
blg pas beaucoup vu les actionnaires
venir faire des déclarations devant la
presse pour dire eh bien cette année je
vais mettre à contribution une partie de
mon bénéfice pour le redonner au profit
des entreprises et des salariés pour
pouvoir affronter la crise peut-être que
ça c'est un sujet aussi qu on pourrait
discuter ensemble
merci françois homélie le président de
la cfe cgc d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france merci à vous merci
et alors que les cinémas sont fermés
depuis maintenant presque un an
plusieurs manifestations ont eu lieu ce
week-end les protestataires réclament la
réouverture des salles dans le respect
des règles sanitaires idem pour les
théâtres toujours assiégés par les
intermittents du spectacle et précision
avec robin publ
le cinéma se rebelle
à l'image du mouvement d'occupation des
théâtres plusieurs opérations coup de
poing ont eu lieu dans les salles
obscures de l'hexagone ce week-end des
actes symboliques
un an jour pour jour après la première
fermeture des lieux culturels pour cause
de crise sanitaire
depuis les salles de cinéma cumule plus
de 240 jours de fermeture et aucun
calendrier de reprise d'activité n'a été
proposée par le ministère de la culture
pourtant plusieurs protocoles sanitaires
sont validées par les experts
scientifiques des études partout dans le
monde ont démontré qu'il n'y a eu aucun
cas de contamination par la coc u19
qu'elle a été déclarée dans un cinéma on
accole sanitaire qui a reconnu comme
étant un des plus strictes et un des
plus compatibles le dire avec le la
propagation de l'épidémie
donc ici la salle fait 420 places à on a
moyen même en réduisant encore les
jauges d'accueillir le public dans
d'excellentes conditions sanitaires
depuis le 30 octobre et la deuxième mise
sous cloche du pays
les cinémas et tous les lieux de culture
sont à l'arrêt des restrictions
sanitaires drastiques alors que la
circulation du public a été autorisé par
le gouvernement dans les lieux de culte
les transports ou dans certains
commerces
un deux poids deux mesures que les
acteurs du monde de la culture ont du
mal à accepter
pourquoi on peut prendre un tgv en étant
à 20 centimètres d'une personne et
pourquoi ne peut pas aller au théâtre ça
n'a pas de sens donc c'est ça que nous
dénonçons on veut bien
on sait qu'il ya une pandémie on est pas
un on n'est pas des martiens tombe pas
de n'importe où on a tous une famille en
protège les nôtres on protège nos
voisins on protège voilà pourquoi le
commerce la marchandisation a droit de
cité
pourquoi les magasins les commerces dans
le centre ville de marseille ont le
droit d'ouvrir et pourquoi a tout d'un
coup tout ce qui a lieu tout ce qui a
trait à la pensée à l'affect à la voilà
à l'échangé d'idées à la réflexion n'a
pas droitiser pourquoi l image des
restaurateurs certains lieux de culture
clandestins apparaissent tout au long du
week-end une vingtaine de salles de
cinéma à paris marseille en bretagne ou
en normandie on projetait des films
inédits dans des conditions sanitaires
très strictes
un premier tour de chauffe non autorisée
pour forcer la main du gouvernement à la
réouverture des salles twitter a
suspendu momentanément pour harcèlement
le compte 2000 adolescente iséroise qui
avait déjà vu sa vie basculer en
publiant en janvier 2020 une vidéo dans
laquelle proférées à de virulents qui
elle proféré de violentes critiques sur
l'islam
la jeune fille qui compte plus de vingt
mille abonnés avaient posté en soirée de
vieux dessins d'enfants ce avant d'être
la cible de milliers de messages
d'insultés et de menaces
devant plusieurs réactions indignées la
société américaine a reconnu une erreur
et a rétabli le compte douze heures
après alors le réseau social twitter at
il fait une simple erreur comme il le
dit 'oui' at-il cédé aux ennemis de la
démocratie comme le dit marine le pen
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
graphiques chez cat avocat cofondateur
de l'association action contre
l'islamophobie bonsoir à rafik chez 4
merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés pour
débattre julien aux 12 membres du bureau
national du r'n conseiller municipal de
sens bon soir julien on double merci
également à vous d'être là c'est donc
une affaire qui a fait bondir au niveau
des politiques de droite et d'extrême
droite ou le week-end regardez par
exemple de tweets de la présidente du
rassemblement national marine le pen
ferment le conte d'une jeune femme
harcelée et menacée par les islamistes
twitter a choisi le camp des ennemis de
la démocratie
il est temps de protéger la liberté
d'expression face aux pouvoirs
exorbitants de ses plateformes privées
et leurs abus répétés rien twitter qui a
donc choisi le camp des ennemis de la
démocratie pour marine le pen est ce que
vous partagez cet avis rafik chez cat
alors avant toute chose j'aimerais
relever l'ironie qu'il ya discuté de la
question de la liberté d'expression avec
un homme donc avec monsieur julien odoul
qui s'est fait connaître du grand public
justement parce qu'il s'est opposé à la
liberté d'expression d'une femme d'une
femme musulmane
c'est à dire qu'il s'est opposé à la
liberté religieuse d'une femme élancée
que cette liberté religieuse est
constitutive de la liberté d'expression
dont je voulais juste relever cette
ironie qui consiste à discuter de cette
question là avec ce monsieur
ensuite j'ai une impression que avant de
rentrer dans le vif du sujet que la
liberté d'expression en france n'est
invoquée que pour revendiquer le droit
d'insulter les musulmanes et les
musulmans c'est à dire que quand des
lanceurs d'alert sont menacés sont
traînés en justice durant des années
sans condamner à payer des amendes
records pour avoir révélé des
malversations financières ou économiques
politiques des scandales politiques ou
bien même des catastrophes écologiques
environnementales
personne ne s'inquiète la d atteinte
manifeste est flagrante à la liberté
d'expression de la même manière toutes
les personnes qui aujourd'hui comme
monsieur oudoul et comme le
rassemblement national monte au créneau
pour défendre milla on aimerait beaucoup
les entendre aussi quand la liberté de
manifester qui est une autre
liberté d'expression est battu en brèche
systématiquement est quasiment chaque
week end par la majorité actuelle
c'est-à-dire que quand le fait de
manifester quand le fait de manifester
ses opinions politiques à l'occasion
d'un mouvement social vous expose
aujourd'hui très concrètement en france
à être menacée à être gazés à être
mutilés où sont les curés ou sont tous
les défenseurs de la liberté
d'expression à ce moment là de la même
manière je terminerais là dessus oui
quand la liberté d'exprimer ses opinions
politiques des militants de la campagne
bds est battu en brèche également quand
on empêche ces militants de la campagne
bds d'exprimer des opinions politiques
c'est à dire le boycott des produits
israéliens en soutien aux populations
palestiniennes personnes là aussi ne
s'enquiert de la liberté d'expression
donc j'ai vraiment l'impression que la
liberté d'expression en france n'étant
invoquées que man va on va laisser le
droit de réponse à julien odoul oui ne
me parlez pas de liberté expression
monsieur chez 4 ne me parlez pas de
liberté d'expression
vous qui être l'avocat du cause qui est
la cause de l'islamisme
il n'ya pas d'islamophobie en france ce
système aux phobiques est un concept
inventé de toutes pièces par les ennemis
mme démocratie par les ennemis de nos
valeurs par les ennemis de nos libertés
justement pour interdire toute critique
de cette idéologie nauséabonde mortifère
qu'est l'islamisme
alors alors vous voyez excusez moi moi
la liberté d'expression oui je la de
total total c'est à dire que milla
cette jeune lycéenne qui est persécuté
depuis un an
persécuté menacé de mort qui a été
déscolarisés parce qu'elle a donné son
opinion a donné son opinion sur une
autre opinion parce que la religion
musulmane comme toutes les religions en
droit français n'est qu'une opinion une
opinion qui peut être critiqué avec
outrance
voilà c'est notre mode de vie 'cela fait
le droit on peut critiquer une religion
de kout france n'a pas le droit de
s'attaquer aux croyants on n'a pas le
droit de s'attaquer des personnes pour
leurs convictions religieuses mais on a
le droit
évidemment de critiques et de s'attaquer
à une religion et même on a le droit
d'en avoir peur voyez on a le droit en
france d'être cathophobes être
judéophobe être islamophobe donc ne me
parlez pas de liberté d'expression parce
que le coup
à qui le vôtre l'entreprise qui est la
vôtre elle cherche justement à museler
la société française et à faire en sorte
que l'idéologie qui est derrière est
encore une fois qui est extrêmement
dangereuse pour la préservation de nos
libertés cette idéologie s'installe donc
moi je trouve ça scandaleux
en tout cas que des encore il faut coder
des françaises et des français comme
milla mais comme d'autres soient
censurées à la fois sur les réseaux
sociaux mais soit surtout menacée
aujourd'hui de mort pour leurs opinions
effectivement il avait été menacé de
mort cette adolescente 1 en janvier 2020
après avoir publié une vidéo qui
critiquaient durement l'islam un autre
réaction politique
aujourd'hui celle du député européen
socialiste dans cette fois raphaël
enthoven
rendez-nous 1000 à quand une femme est
menacée de mort c'est elle qu'on protège
pas les assassins putatif attention les
cons
ceci n'est pas une insulte et leurs
graphiques chez 4 c'est vrai que sur le
message quand on a enlevé le compte de
millas y avait indiqué un tweeter
suspend les comptes qui ont fraigne les
règles de twitter c'est vrai que cette
confusion entre celui qu'on doit
protéger celui qu'on attaque c'est un
petit peu compliqué vous comprenez que
ça ait pu choquer à droite comme à
gauche on viens de l'entendre je vais
pas redire ce que j'ai dit sur le double
standard est la manière dont on est
choqué pour certaines atteintes et non
pour d'autres moins très honnêtement sur
l'inter milan est sur cette jeune fille
j'ai pas vraiment je n'ai même aucune
opinion sur cette personne à dire que je
vais pas me mettre à commenter les
tweets que tout jeune personne fait sur
twitter
c'est absolument pas de mon ressort par
contre j'aimerais dire une chose qui
peut paraître surprenant c'est que j'en
veux à toutes les personnes qui ont
servi de caisse de résonance à cette
jeune femme à cette jeune personne qui
tweets sur twitter moi je suis pour que
les personnes puissent écrire à peu près
ce qu'elles veulent sur les réseaux
sociaux et notamment sur twitter valette
et c'est pour ça qu'elle a été
médiatisée elle a été vraiment menacé de
mort des squales et déscolarisé cétacés
j'en vois exactement à toutes les
personnes qui ont servi et je le redis
de caisse de résonance à cette personne
parce que c'est huit sont insignifiants
sa pensée politique et ces opinions sont
parfaitement insignifiante et je ne
comprends même pas qu'on puisse monter
en épingle à terre comme ça donc je vous
le dis j'en veux aux pics des personnes
qui relaie cette personne milla qui
devrait rester dans la limite étant dans
l'anonymat pardon qui devrait être le
sien qui aurait dû être le sien
aujourd'hui
j'ai l'air au dos oui malheureusement
aujourd'hui milla ne peut pas être
anonyme
milla ne peut pas avoir la vie d'une
jeune fille française normal aujourd'hui
la vie de millas est un enfer et c'est
un enfer parce qu'elle est persécuté en
raison de ses opinions
elle est persécutée par des gens qui
peuvent se donner
ils peuvent donner libre cours à des
discours de haine à la fois sur les
réseaux sociaux mais aussi dans la
société parce que ce que l'on peut voir
sur les réseaux sociaux
on le retrouve dans les entreprises on
le retrouve dans les clubs de sport on
le retrouve sur évidemment dans les
services publics on le retrouve à
l'école on le retrouve dans la vie
réelle et moi ce que je dénonce c'est le
deux poids deux mesures aussi parce que
milla le le k 2000 à vous en avez
d'autres évidemment vous avez les
professeurs de lieux paix à grenoble
vous avez tous ceux aujourd'hui qui
osent critiquer l'islam qui osent
critiquer le voile islamique qui ont se
défendre la laïcité tout simplement
qu'ils se retrouvent persécutés qui
subissent des fatwas et qui peuvent
quelquefois comme ça mais elle pâtit
comme le regretté sam elle pâtit peuvent
y laisser la vie
et moi ce que je regrette c'est que la
prétendue islamophobie qui est ce
concept voit la nébuleuse islamiste
la prétendue islamophobie elle n'existe
pas dans les faits et je prends juste un
exemple la jeune qui a menti sur samuel
pâti cette jeune élève du collège de
samuel pâtit donc qui a proféré ce
mensonge qui a conduit à la décapitation
de sa mère pattie cette jeune fille
n'est pas déscolarisés cette jeune fille
n'est pas persécutés et tant mieux pour
elle parce qu'évidemment je ne pense
qu'aujourd'hui elle subit les
conséquences de son acte mais cette
jeune fille a pu réintégrer son
établissement scolaire ce qui n'est pas
le cas de milan milla été déscolarisés
aujourd'hui milla est tous sous
protection policière voilà la différence
entre des preuves des prétendues
victimes d' islamophobie est celle qui
est ce qu'ils sont taxés d'islamophobe
qui pour le coup vivent un enfer et sont
menacés de mort avant de vous faire
réagir afic chekade voulez vous faire
entendre cette dernière réaction celle
d'un professeur d'histoire géo en
seine-saint-denis qui vient souvent
d'ailleurs débattre dans cette émission
voici ce qu'il en pense la ferme il a
restauré dans notre histoire récente
comme le symbole du renoncement de la
république à imposer ses valeurs à ce
qui l'a conspué
c'est le communautarisme qui l'emportent
sur le vivre ensemble c'est la loi
coranique qui l'emportent sur celles de
la république
rafik h et 4 votre réaction c'est le
communautarisme qui l'emportent sur le
sur le vivre ensemble vous comprenez que
certains aujourd'hui puisse le penser
ou ça vous alors si demandé à ce
professeur d'histoire géographie de
définir tous les termes qu'il vient
d'employés après en premier lieu le
communautarisme le vivre ensemble etc
il serait bien en peine de donner une
définition précise de ces mots là donc
on agite sont ce qu'on appelle des
mots-valises le communautarisme c'est à
dire qu'il ya autant de définitions de
communes du mot communautariser qu'il ya
personne qu'il utilise donc parler
aujourd'hui comme vient de le faire
monsieur odoul de cette personne qui ose
critiquer l'islam alors qu'il suffit
aujourd'hui d'allumer n'importe quelle
radio d'ouvrir n'importe quel journal
d'allumer n'importe quel poste de
télévision sur n'importe quelle chaîne
d'information continue pour voir que les
débats sur l'islam sont incessants la
semaine dernière c'était lieu baie de
grenoble après on discute de la question
de la pertinence du terme d'islamophobie
ou non et j'aimerais dire une chose
c'est que l'islamophobie est présente
dans tous les pays d'europe
évidemment dans toutes les sociétés
occidentales mayhem spécificité
française c'est que la france est à mon
sens le seul pays d'europe et deux
seules la seule démocratie occidentale
où l'on discute à ce point de la
pertinence ou non de ce terme
et c'est révélateur du climat qu'il ya
dans ce pays donc vraiment moi tous les
propos qui consiste à dire que
l'islamophobie est un racisme qui
n'existe pas et c'est alors qu'on vient
de voter une loi la loi séparatiste
entraver les personnes musulmanes dans
tous les aspects de leur vie sociale que
ce soit le travail l'éducation le vous
ai pas couper la parole monsieur décès -
finir je ne vous ai pas couper la parole
laissez moi juste fidjiens et c'est
moins finir monsieur je vous ai pas
couper la parole non je n'ai pas coupé
la parole donnée c'est pour dire non
mais laissez moi finir monsieur ou toul
alors pour finir c'est plus on donnera
droit est ingénieur au delà les y
raconte la direction monsieur vodoun
c'est ma toute première télévision je
vous ai pas couper la parole et c'est
terminé c'est parce qu'on arrive au bout
du débat je termine elle termine par
dire que toutes les il y à noeux en
france le terme islamophobie est lié par
les plus grands propagateurs de
l'islamophobie même et c'est ce qui est
intéressant et vous en êtes la
manifestation ce soir monsieur otto gelé
aux douleurs rapidement s'il vous plaît
le mot de la fin rapidement merci la
même monsieur je vous apprendre quelque
chose mais en france il n'y a aucune loi
qui entravent le nos compatriotes de
confession musulmane pour la simple et
bonne raison que la religion passe après
la noce nationalité la citoyenneté
ils sont français avant tout il n'y a
pas d'exception n'a pas d'exception pour
les musulmans pour les catholiques
ils ont français avant tout voilà et
toutes les lois s'appliquent à tout le
monde
merci merci à tous les deux en tout cas
d'avoir accepté le jeu du face à face et
oui c'est le principe nous ne sommes pas
d'accord rafik chez ktm julien odoul est
évidemment raphaël entre ben et bien
philosophe et non pas député européen
socialiste veuillez nous excuser pour
cette erreur
merci à vous dans quelques instants
rester avec nous nous parlerons de
l'allemagne au lendemain d'un revers
cinglant pour le parti d'angela merkel
dans deux scrutins régionaux un
avertissement sérieux à six mois des
élections fédérales allemandes et puis
direction les états unis où le
gouverneur de l'état de new york accusé
d'harcèlement sexuel pourrait être amené
à démissionner dans les jours qui
viennent
[Musique]
l'actualité hervé morin c'est évidemment
la crise sanitaire ce que je défends
c'est bien sûr la territorialisation de
la gestion de l'épidémie on voit bien qu
un système centralisé bureaucratique tel
que celui ci a produit toute une série
de dysfonctionnements pas masquer dans
un premier temps pas de test dans un
second temps puis désormais une
insuffisance de vaccins on a senti que
vous étiez nerveux et agacé à l'encontre
de la politique de l'exécutif quant à au
déploiement de la vaccination et je
constate c'est qu'on est le 36e pays en
matière de vaccination
bon ça prouve à quel point on a un
système efficace
en normandie on aura deux usines qui
bientôt produiront des vaccins qui pour
la va être bientôt autorisés sur le
marché compte tenu de la faiblesse de la
vaccination je vois pas comment dans
quatre à six semaines
on pourrait se retrouver libéré
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h30 merci nous rejoindre en direct sur
rt france en allemagne le parti d'angela
merkel promet d'améliorer sa gestion de
la pandémie
une déclaration qui intervient au
lendemain d'un revers cinglant dans deux
scrutins régionaux
l'union chrétienne démocrate enregistré
son pire score et c'est un avertissement
sérieux pour les conservateurs à six
mois des élections législatives
fédérales qui doit aboutir à l'élection
du nouveau chancelier
les précisions de peter oliver
correspondant aux pertes et à berlin
cela va où devraient tirer la sonnette
d'alarmé pour l'union chrétienne
démocrate
ils ont enregistré les pire score de
leur histoire dans deux états clé du sud
ouest de l'allemagne dans le bade
vinterberg est également en rhénanie
palatinat
suite à ce vote il risque sérieusement
de se retrouver exclue du gouvernement
dans ces deux régions au terme du
mercato des coalitions le cas échéant
cela pourrait se traduire par une
répétition au niveau national de ce qui
va arriver au niveau local si l'union
chrétienne démocrate est la grande
perdante
le grand gagnant est le parti vert dans
le bade wurtemberg est également en
rhénanie palatinat où ils sont bien
placés pour faire partie du futur
gouvernement de coalition
selon le dirigeant du parti vers les
électeurs montrent qu'ils ont donc plus
qu'assez du statu quo comme cela a été
mentionné
la cdo et son tendon en bavière l'union
chrétienne sociale sont impliqués dans
un large scandale de corruption qui a
déjà mené à la démission de trois
députés pour ce qu'on a qualifié de
profit de guerre autour de la pandémie
ducobu 10,9
il aurait obtenu de l'argent
autre des contrats pour
l'approvisionnement en eau pays et
masquer ce scandale qui s'ajoute au
mécontentement grandissant vis-à-vis de
la gestion de la pandémie a fait chuter
le bloc de l'union conservatrice à 30 %
dans les sondages nationaux les taux le
plus bas depuis un an
mais l'insatisfaction ne s'exprime pas
que dans les sondages ce week-end est l
anniversaire de la première
manifestation anti confinement
aujourd'hui encore des gens sont
descendus dans les rues d'allemagne pour
exprimer leur mécontentement vis-à-vis
de la gestion de la pandémie par le
gouvernement de coalition
ces résultats au badge hinterberg et en
rhénanie-palatinat ne sont que le début
d'une très grosse année électorale en
allemagne dont l'apothéose sera la
grande élection du bundestag
en septembre nous serons alors qui
prendra la suite dans quel amour qu'elle
continue avec la maison expert en
relations internationales bonsoir claude
donges saison merci d'être avec nous on
l'a entendu de revers électoraux pour le
parti d'être cédée ou mais vraiment une
défaite à titre personnel pour angela
merkel
bon c'est évidemment un échec pour la
céder ou mais je ne crois pas que ce
soit un échec personnel pour madame en
garde américaine pour deux raisons la
première c'est qu'elle a quitté la
présidence de la série ou et à deux ans
et demi en mettant une succession en
place l'actuelle ministre de la défense
a fait un intérim et maintenant il ya un
nouveau président de la cds où est donc
le deuxième successeur de madame merkel
et puis la deuxième raison c'est que en
réalité hier il s'agissait de quoi il
s'agissait de deux élections régionales
très importantes bien sûr de régions qui
sont proches de la france proche de
l'alsace et les gens tout simplement ont
réélu l'administration qui était au
pouvoir dans ces deux régions
et ça n'est pas rien parce que dans les
länder leu leu
le gouvernement local a beaucoup de
pouvoir par exemple il a d'après la
constitution
c'est lui qui a le pouvoir en matière de
santé c'est lui qui a le pouvoir en
matière d'éducation
alors eh bien en effet au bade
wurtemberg on a réélu le
ministre-président puisque cela
s'appelle comme ça qui est inverse qui
est au pouvoir depuis dix ans de mandat
pour montrer sa flexibilité
il ad'ailleurs gouverner pendant cinq
ans avec le seul et socialiste et puis
pendant cinq années avec la cd ou donc
les cinq dernières années avec la cdu ou
est en effet la cd ou a fait un mauvais
score a perdu trois ou quatre points de
pourcentage
et puis dans l'autre dans le nord est ré
rhénanie palatinat et bien là on a une
femme qui est ministre présidente et qui
aussi a bien géré sa région et par
conséquent les électeurs ont été réélus
alors là la cd ou est dans l'opposition
de toute manière puisque le gouvernement
est un gouvernement
rick allert dans mon lit en allemagne
puisqu'il y a les socialistes qui est là
la vice présidente
il y a les verts et il y a les le fdp
c'est à dire les libéraux que l'on
considère comme orange et rouge vert
orange comme les feux de la circulation
dit-on également en allemagne
alors bien sûr la situation se résume
par un avertissement sans frais pour
pour le parti cd ou mais je ne pense pas
que ce soit un désaveu de madame merkel
elle-même pour toutes les raisons que je
viens d'indiquer simplement on retient
en effet comme ça vient d'être unis dans
votre sujet qui a une autre hypothèse
que la grande coalition actuelle à
berlin et l'autre hypothèse pourrait
être un gouvernement tricolore comme
pour le nord rhénanie palatinat avec
d avec d une alliance du spd des
libéraux et des verts mon nom n'est
encore pas là alors on l'aura compris la
course à la chancellerie est bel et bien
lancée qui a le plus de chances d'être
le prochain ou la prochaine chancelière
alors si tu enlèves ou comme vous le
dites prochain prochaine puisque les
verts n'ont pas encore désigné leurs
candidats et qu' ils auront à choisir
entre un député qui est un universitaire
jeune avec beaucoup de charisme et puis
une candidate qui elle aussi est député
et il y aura donc un candidat vert
peut-être que la poussée fera que les
verts arrivent en tête
ça n'est pas sûr pour ce qui est de la
cd ou et bien logiquement c'est le
président qui a été désigné au mois de
janvier delà de la cdo qui devrait
porter les couleurs de la cd ou pour les
élections du 26 septembre prochain ce
n'est pas absolument certain parce que
il a un opposant à l'intérieur de la
confédération c'est deus ex ou qui est
le président de l'abps sessou parti
bavarois mais qui est plus conservateur
que lui par conséquent il ya moins de
capacité à faire alliance avec d'autres
partis
or on ne peut gouverner à berlin qu'avec
une coalition par conséquent il faut
avoir des capacités de conclure des
alliances et on verra en effet si le
prochain chancelier ou la prochaine
chancelière et du parti vert écologistes
du parti socialiste du spd ou bien de la
cd ou cs où il est encore trop tôt pour
le dire
la chancelière en tout cas a dit
clairement qu'elle excluait de faire un
cinquième mandat
et comme c'est une scientifique après
tout les spécialistes de la physique des
particules et elle a évalué ses chances
elle a aussi évalué son parcours et elle
considère qu'elle doit maintenant
s'arrêter alors l'allemagne la grande
élection du bundestag en septembre la
france élections présidentielles en 2020
quelle sera la future relation entre
l'allemagne et la france
à chaque fois qu'un changement de
chancelier août chancelière en allemagne
à chaque fois qu'il ya un changement de
président de la république en france
cela se traduit par une période
d'ajustement par une période où on se
comprend moins bien mais finalement les
intérêts communs sont tellement
importants que après cette période
d'ajustement
eh bien la france et l'allemagne
s'assoient pour retrouver des positions
communes et pour réduire leurs
différends
spontanément bien sûr les intérêts
peuvent être divergents mais en réalité
les intérêts supérieurs étant beaucoup
plus important et convergents eh bien on
finit toujours par trouver une solution
alors il y aura également un troisième
élément dans le premier semestre de
l'année 2022 c'est que la présidence
tournante de l'union européenne
pendant ce semestre eh bien c'est la
france qu'il exercera et par conséquent
le président de la république française
prépare déjà le lancement de cette
présidence le 1er janvier prochain et il
la prépare avec madame merkel il la
prépare à avec le sucesseur ou la
successeure de madame merkel
et puis on verra bien ce qui se passera
à l'élection présidentielle française
mais la france est un état de droit qu'à
une anémie une administration un système
politique suffisamment solides pour que
quel que soit le résultat des élections
présidentielles en france
eh bien la france exerce normalement sa
présidence pendant les six mois au
conseil à bruxelles
merci claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales
les pays-bas entame ce lundi trois jours
d'élections législatives scrutin
considéré comme un test de la gestion de
l'épidémie par le gouvernement actuel
à la veille de ce rendez vous électoral
une nouvelle manifestation a eu lieu à
l'est contre la politique de restriction
sanitaire du premier ministre sortant
marc route eux qui semble pourtant bien
placé pour être réélu à un quatrième
mandat
c'est le premier scrutin national pour
un état européen organisé en pleine
épidémie et sur fond de contestations
walid bettany elle la douche froide pour
les qu'ovide sceptiques
chassés de leur terrain de jeu le ton
qui monte
[Applaudissements]
certains manifestants à terre menotté
ce dimanche les forces de l'ordre
appelées en renfort à la veille
d'élections législatives déterminantes
entre intimidations et parfois
répression
[Applaudissements]
un ordre d'urgence lancé par la police
pour disperser la foule et faire
respecter les règles sanitaires
le gouvernement du premier ministre
marco route eux en ligne de mire la
coalition au pouvoir composée de quatre
parties a décidé de serrer
progressivement la vis depuis mi
décembre
aujourd'hui le pays est sous couvre feu
jusqu'au 31 mars de vente et une heure à
4h30 du matin l'eau coronavirus sujet
numéro un de tension de frustration
depuis plusieurs semaines mais les
politiques néerlandais souhaite aborder
d'autres sujets je pense que la réponse
honnête et qu'après la fin de l'épisode
du coronavirus de nombreux problèmes que
nous avions seront de nouveau sur la
table avec une revanche en terme de
création d'une économie solidaire
ajustée mais aussi forte de construction
d'une société sûre et sécurisée
je pense que ça devrait être l'enjeu de
ces élections on parle trop ducobu dans
quelques ça alors que ces élections sont
un moment nous devons décider qui est un
tournant en termes d'investissements
importants nécessaires pour l'éducation
les emplois du futur l'économie verte
est comme gelée mentionné la lutte
contre la crise climatique d'autres
partis pendant encore au pouvoir espère
jouer la carte de la fidélité comme la
deuxième formation du pays celle de
guerre de leader avec pour principal axe
de campagne l'immigration sans oublier
la problématique du futur l'écologie
porté par jessy clever 34 ans nous
voulons rejoindre la coalition
nous aimerions travailler avec tous les
autres partis de gauche et les partis
progressistes pour nous assurer qu'il y
aura un gouvernement de gauche vers un
gouvernement vert est aussi un
gouvernement pro européen afin que le
changement que nous préconisons dans
cette campagne nous puissions le
réaliser al'approche des élections le
premier ministre marko route eux a
autorisé début mars la réouverture des
salons de coiffure et massage ainsi que
celle partielle des lycées et collèges
les magasins dits non essentielles
peuvent aussi accueillir un maximum de
deux clients sur rendez vous l'intérieur
des restaurants et bars reste cependant
toujours fermés aux états unis le
gouverneur de l'état de new york
pourrait être amené à démissionner dans
les jours à venir andrew cuomo est
accusé de harcèlement sexuel et de
nombreux élus démocrates réclament son
départ
le président des dden de son côté botte
en touche leila zahaf
andrew qu au mois de nouveau refusé de
démissionner ce vendredi assurant comme
la semaine précédente n'avoir pas fait
les choses dont il a été accusé
une enquête a été ouverte pour établir
la vérité sur les allégations
d'agressions sexuelles et de
comportement inapproprié à l'égard de
six jeunes femmes de son entourage
privée et professionnelle s'il reconnaît
partiellement les faits sans excuse il
conteste la notion de harcèlement et
d'agressions
le président américain joe biden a
esquivé ce dimanche les questions des
journalistes
l'enquêté est en cours et il nous faut
voir ce qu'elle apportera la chef
démocrate de la chambre des
représentants nancy pelosi est l'invité
andrew qu au mois se demandait s'il
était toujours en mesure d'occuper son
poste sans aller jusqu'à réclamer sa
démission le gouverneur m new york il
doit sonder son coeur pour voir s'il
peut encore diriger l'état avec
efficacité lors de ces révélations
j'avais affirmé que ces femmes qui ont
dénoncé le gouverneur devait être prise
au sérieux cette fois ci il ne s'agit
plus uniquement d'une poignée d'élus qui
souhaitent le voir partir 55 députés
démocrates sur 105 du même parti à
l'assemblée de l'état de new york ont
voté jeudi dernier en faveur du
lancement d'une procédure d'impeachment
au vu des multiples pinte d'harcèlement
et des nombreuses allégations
d'agression sexuelle il est évident que
le gouverneur cuomo a perdu la confiance
de ses partenaires au pouvoir ainsi que
des new yorkais c'est pourquoi je pense
que le gouverneur doit démissionner
depuis vendredi c'est au tour
d'influents élus démocrates new yorkais
de la chambre des représentants de
réclamer le départ du gouverneur s'il
devait continuer à s'accrocher à un
poste qu'il occupe depuis sa première
élection en 2010 celle une procédure de
destitution semble pouvoir obliger
andreu o mo à partir contre son gré une
telle procédure sans précédent dans
l'état de new york depuis 1913 requiert
une majorité simple à la chambre basse
et les deux tiers à la chambre haute
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
gérald olivier chercheur à l'institut de
prospective et de sécurité en europe
journaliste franco américain bonsoir
gérald audigier merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france on le voit la
pression monte assure andrew cuomo est
ce qu'il peut tenir à son poste au moins
le temps de l'enquète oui bonsoir vous
avez raison la pression monte mais pour
l'instant c'est surtout une pression
médiatique et j'aurais quand même
insisté sur un fait c'est qu'il ya des
accusations qui pèsent contre lui mais
même aux etats-unis aujourd'hui pour
l'instant tant qu'il n'y a pas eu procès
tant qu'il n'y a pas eu jugement tant
qu'il n'y a pas eu condamnation
toute personne est présumée innocente
jusqu'à avoir été trouvé coupable
donc pour moi ces allégations même si
elles sont vraies et elles sont très
probablement avéré parce qu'elle a
suffisamment maintenant pour que une
certaine cohérence autour de tout cela
mais elle ne devrait pas suffire à faire
que le gouverneur démissionne il me
semble beaucoup plus graves par exemple
ce qui s'est passé concernant sa gestion
de la pandémie de co vide et notamment
le fait qu' il ait délibérément caché au
public la réalité du nombre des décès
notamment dans les ehpad de l'état de
new york
ça c'est une faute je dirais
administrative qui est beaucoup plus
grave et qui d'ailleurs est en train de
susciter de la part de certains de ses
adversaires
une démarche d' impeachment comme l'a
souligné votre reportage donc andrew
cuomo est manifestement en grande
difficulté ils pourraient ils pourraient
abandonner en démissionnant
immédiatement pour moi il n'est pas
encore acculé d'olivier pourtant
pourtant joe biden 1 et nancy pelosi on
l'a vu sont pas dans l'embarras mais en
tout cas botte en touche il n'y a pas
vraiment
voilà de lâchage du démocrate comeau qui
restent dans les rangs du parti
démocrate et qui reste tout de même
d'une certaine manière soutenue tout à
fait vous avez parfaitement raison mais
en même temps ce n'est pas à eux de le
faire ce n'est pas leur rôle
et ce serait une situation très
embarrassante
on va dire que les les démocrates sont
beaucoup plus embarrassé qu'il ne paraît
par cette situation
ils sont pour l'instant protégé par une
presse qui en dehors de new york n'est
pas totalement contre leur propre camp
qui en tous les cas ne cherche pas à
prétendre que ce qui est arrivé ou ceux
qui arrivent à andrew cuomo ou ceux dont
andrew comme au 1er responsable
représente exactement l'attitude de tous
les personnages politiques démocrates
donc pour l'instant à washington on
cherche surtout comme vous dites a botté
en touche c'est à dire à ne pas
s'impliquer dans un sens ou dans un
autre
à ne pas prononcer une parole qui
pourrait dans quelques jours ou dans
quelques semaines avoir des conséquences
qu'on imagine pas aujourd'hui alors
andrew cuomo lui se défend avec vigueur
assurant que les allégations contre lui
sont fausses et laissant entendre qu'il
était une nouvelle victime
je cite de la can cette culture qui fait
rage actuellement aux etats unis
l'argument de cancelles cultura on
rappelle pour ceux qui l'ignoreraient
ans qui pousse en retrait en gros de la
sphère publique de personnalités jugées
coupables d'abus aux discriminations
contre les minorités sexuelles ou
ethnique
cet argument est ce qu'ils les entendent
abs que justement il illustre clivage au
sein d'eads et du parti démocrate
alors pour moi le cac locomo ce n'est
pas de la can son coach le cac ou homo
c'est les conséquences du mit tout
mouvement
c'est à dire le mythe ou mouvements tout
vous souvenez qui est née avec la ferme
aux ânes stein où ce grand producteur de
hollywood a été accusé de viol de
harcèlement sexuel par par plusieurs
femmes des faits qui remontaient à très
longtemps mais qui s'était produit sur
une très longue durée et sur lesquels
beaucoup de gens avaient alors
fermez les yeux depuis ce moment là dès
qu'on a une à l'ogre une commande irène
allégations de harcèlement sexuel et
bien la personne visée est supposé en
effet se retirer immédiatement
donc elle est condamnée avant qu'il y
ait jugement c'est ça d'ailleurs que je
critiquais en tout début de mon
intervention quand j'ai répondu à votre
première question
ça c'est le mouvement au mythe ou dont
il est question lorsque rendre vos mots
parlent de cannes son coach la can son
corps je regrette c'est autre chose
la can sans coach c'est le fait d
d'éliminer de marginaliser toute pensée
dissidente vis à vis d'un certain nombre
de principes qui aujourd'hui régis là on
va dire la pensée progressiste et c'est
faire en sorte notamment que toute
pensée conservatrice et tous les
républicains et tous les supporters de
trompe soit immédiatement targuer de
raciste de suprémaciste blanc est donc
mis hors du champ politique la can sans
cochin c'est ça la can sur corner
consiste à éliminer les personnes qui
sont en désaccord avec vous sans pour
autant avoir d'une manière ou d'une
autre fauté alors que là les allégations
qui concerne le gouverneur comme au son
des allégations très graves aussi bien
d'un point de vue administrative parce
qu'il aurait quand même menti et il a
dissimulé un certain nombre de faits
concernant la pandémie
et puis après des accusations qui
portent sur un comportement personnel ce
n'est pas du même niveau mais c'est tout
aussi grave
mais ces fautes je dirais de
comportement nécessite qu'il n'y a eu
une enquête et pas simplement une
accusation et qu'à partir d'une
accusation
une personne se retrouve immédiatement
détruites ça c'est un petit peu exagéré
quand même alors il ya une femme qui va
jouer un rôle important et c'est
d'ailleurs le point commun entre andrew
comoé donald trump
letitia james à la procureur général de
l'état de new york qui a en ligne de
mire d'ailleurs les deux hommes qui
semble d'une certaine manière
intouchable ce qu'elle peut les obliger
letitia james rendez compte alors elle a
un rôle très important et elle a
beaucoup de pouvoir parce que aux états
unis le procureur est la personne qui je
dirais dirige les affaires
néanmoins
elle a elle doit faire je dirais non pas
attention mais il faut qu'elle s'assure
que son dossier soit je dirais blindés
parce que malgré tout le gouverneur de
new york
c'est pas le premier quidam venu et
encore une fois il y à un système
politique qui le protège c'est à dire
que tant qu'il n'a pas été condamné par
une cour de justice
il n'est tenu à rien sur le plan
politique
donc elle a beaucoup de pouvoir contre
lui elle a beaucoup de pouvoirs dans ce
dossier mais c'est à elle de bien gérer
merci beaucoup gérald olivier chercheur
à l'institut de prospective et de
sécurité en europe journaliste
franco-américaine remercie d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france et
c'est la fin de cette émission rester
avec nous dans quelques instants un
point complet sur l'actualité de la
journée
[Musique]
l'actualité hervé morin c'est évidemment
la crise sanitaire ce que je défends
c'est bien sûr la territorialisation de
la gestion de l'épidémie on voit bien qu
un système centralisé bureaucratique tel
que celui ci a produit toute une série
de dysfonctionnements pas masquer dans
un premier temps pas de test dans un
second temps puis désormais une
insuffisance de vaccins on a senti que
vous étiez nerveux et agacé à l'encontre
de la politique de l'exécutif
quant à au déploiement de la vaccination
et je constate c'est que l'on est le 36e
pays en matière de vaccination
bon ça prouve à quel point on a un
système efficace
en normandie on aura deux usines qui
bientôt produiront des vaccins qui pour
la va être bientôt autorisés sur le
marché compte tenu de la faiblesse de la
vaccination je vois pas comment dans
quatre à six semaines
on pourrait se retrouver libéré
[Musique]
et il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre la table
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du public
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï pj jones étaient
des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer qu une
sixième république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
mecs ne sont pas toujours respectées les
couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire je suis chômeur et chaque
semaine dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes le désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager